well welcome welcome to your palms house
[Music]
you should see me when we drive by a
bike store you should see me when we
drive by of ice
[Music]
there you go
that's cool it was called stranger bikes
and it's by C Nick and Steven snick and
Steven it says I like that there you go
you know I love it like that stranger
bikes playing off the stranger things
theme I can't wait for that show to come
back it's coming back to when I guess
there's a big uproar right now people
are upset that they didn't renew since
eight I couldn't get into that I tried
and I couldn't did you try I don't I saw
the pilot that's the only thing I saw
I couldn't yeah well they did actually
we had people all over the world right
today just passed super powers like one
guy can come a lot and then the other
ladies I missed that episode entirely
you didn't know that nope are they all
going to come strike no I think you're
confusing that with something else
one of them can talk to Hitler no no no
I don't think so I don't think that can
happen
we tried watching last Rock yes did you
do your exercise this weekend while I
was away yeah did work done how many did
you get through I got 250
but that's getting that's progress
your first if you drove you to get 300
spoken yeah and then I possibly have an
orgasm just not ejaculate but have the
orgasm happened on the inside how do you
I hear that happens when you when you
get sniped rah rah rah that you in the
beginning I'll thank you but gawk
anything and you get sniped when you get
a vasectomy
oh that you might not I don't think you
make of a gawk at the beginning and then
you make something no dr. drew was
saying that he doesn't have any juice
that comes out because he had a I
wouldn't know he had Yetta as test if
your cancer sorry nervous like to me oh
yeah yeah because vasectomy you still
see him but not the potent load yeah
yeah no sperm
there's no power minutes
part of firms firms lay shrimps yeah
firms
yes people do miss pluralize that sperms
shrimps a lot I hate that especially if
they just had an expresso uh I gave that
and I just came from the library the
expresso one makes me the most upset
because I hear servers and baristas yes
I know anyone extra shot of espresso in
that yeah how do you work here you
should know and you've read it on the
menu
Overlord yeah stupid suck sperms man
sperms so it was oh so we tried watching
yesterday after porn ends to hoping to
find yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
hoping to find some gems in there like
we did with the other porno documentary
yeah where she was like she did that
hooker map
segment remember it was the best to a DA
he'll remember the math go ahead and
math what I did Matt the Matt a hooker
math was you get like I don't know five
hundred dollars to shoot a scene right
she's going over it she's yes but they
offer you to let a guy come inside of
you
yeah an internal surprise an extra
hundred dollars Ryan goes so get an
extra hundred bucks he comes inside then
you know a the morning-after pill the
plan B is only forty dollars only 40
hours so that sixty bucks are going to
keep in my pocket
if the win-win is which all I gotta do
is let this dude I don't know coming me
on camera so that's needed to mortalized
forever what's wrong with that
what'd you get 60 bucks huh like I was
telling you a bit if if she had been
like and then for like a guy to finish
inside you know I get another four
hundred dollars really well you know
that that makes sense
you're like okay that makes sense 400
ollars will be worth a guy anyone that
you just talking like what scumbags the
like that industry is run by they don't
even go like here's 140
so the four you get to plan because
family get make $100 they're like you
figure it out you're doing whatever
whatever you got it on you maybe you
want the kid who knows yeah don't you
yeah so we were looking for some gems
but apparently these porn stars they
followed are too smart and they figured
out how they were going I think we got
to keep think we should finish it
because if you notice they would go cue
uplifting for me well they would go they
would go different types of stories like
up and down right so like they would do
one person who was like it was bias back
then and now I'm have you know I'm
retired and and marry yeah dogs and then
so like that's a kind of a sweeter story
then you go to the guys like I have AIDS
talk shit and then they go to the lady
who was like I had a lot of fun doing it
and you know it's crazy blah blah blah
so I think we should I think if we keep
watching we're going to get somewhere
yeah you know maybe fun if it definitely
wasn't hooker hilarious yeah give me
those hard knocks stories I know his was
like and his HIV story Jesus well to his
credit he looks great like he really
seems to maintain his body well and and
he's working out a lot and he seems
happy oh my god god that dude is like so
extra yoked but I think you got to be
juicing right to be on that body yes
especially with an autoimmune disease
definitely my dad was telling me about
that about some of these bodies you see
on people so like if you don't know top
dog who's obviously been on the show a
million times he was a competitive
Olympic lifter for years I mean from the
time he was 13 till about 29 or 30 and
he was working out six days a week most
of his workouts were like three hours
plus like these guys were maniacs and he
goes you know I was in great shape I was
a two-time state champion I was ranked
nationally because I didn't have a like
the body that you see some of these guys
have right oh wow that was somebody
who's lifting eight every day and eating
steak every day steak potatoes and every
day this was before supplement creatine
or vitamins no roids he's just like
a workout I ate a steak data and that
was was it but it's interesting because
you see these days you see crazy bodies
so especially in men like super sculpted
you know statuesque bodies and but it's
also the era of like people taking
growth hormone and and and test out you
know like sure access yeah access all
writing stuff because with him like I've
seen pictures of him and he's in his
like super competitive lifting days and
looks like a super fit guy they you
don't see like muscles kind of falling
don't really define in the veins and all
that you and your dad are built like
brick shithouse is I think not a shit
brick house I was getting but you do say
that a lot they but you guys are built
for that you're very sturdy and Ellis
has that back to you guys have brought
those shoulders on the back for it we
have the same blueprint my dad yeah in
the direction of working hard at it yeah
right but your genetic I mean you lived
wage we've got with you know gym
whatever I could I could pursue it more
heat but like we we were talking about
his work out some time and I was like
fuck that dude I mean yeah he was
competitive not different I mean I
wouldn't I don't have the desire you and
I both have that lazy gene counteracts
any sort of wanting I forced myself to
swim and do Pilates that I hate it
yelling rube this is the thing that they
would lift as like a team yeah and he
goes like if you left early or skipped
any day the other guys would ride you so
hard about it that you were like fuck
that like they would only go on dates
after you know I mean so if it was like
hey I'll pick you up on Friday and you
go like seven I like Nam 9:30
after I'm done yeah when I'm done
there's a plan Wow so they were so so
that's cool though good cat in mind
right now like in 30 sets
you know folks claw like not to but if
but your dad is the type of personality
who really likes structure and Jesslyn
and focus and like having that you know
when I found an unrelated to this really
interesting watching that documentary
was
she was an old lady now but she did like
the devil and mrs. Jones or whatever
that porno is the old ass one yeah by
the way
she'll uh bitch way old huh good y'all
too old huh she liked the rub rub guy
yeah Letta
so butt out they showed a picture of her
and nude and I was startled by it
because you're like oh yeah that's what
human bodies looked like yeah
prior a nice normal body no and I was
beautiful like a but I forget what
normal bodies look like in print yeah
human bodies with natural breasts that
just set that laid normal and they
weren't enormous quadruple d fuck my
triple d slut wife tits I know I'm
platinum blonde Wow yes please please
please please
looks like it's drawn on like she's in
dead flesh is in shock and the eyebrows
wonder what it is B pop like how did
that I like looking at different looking
women obviously you sure like a variety
mate riot yeah and it's exciting to see
you know but like hungry Ted why did it
gets why it went to like as like that's
hot
because I don't feel like that is I
don't know which committee decided that
all porn chicks have to look identical
because I mean like there are men who
like hungry or tits and big shots and
different shaped faces are interesting
houses different you know all that shit
is interesting you know what I think it
is burnt hair I think the beginning was
Pam Anderson honestly I think sometime
around her era people went oh the gold
standard is blonde is fuck huge tits
tiny tiny waist and Barbie it's
essentially Barbie even actually know
the porn stars body is bigger tits than
what Barbie had Barbie was like a see
sure these bitches are quadruple T G eat
it's super comfortable to slut do you
know like we haven't even started what a
girl look how many interesting topics
we've already gotten we were to get out
more fun maybe a hot ticket yeah do it
let's do the show
let's go let's go let's go
hey get your fucking camera out of here
that's none of your fucking business you
talk bite unless you want trespass you
get the fuck out of here now get out of
here now
don't fuck with me partner you know the
tea our staff is you don't fucking worry
about who I'm with yes who is Randy
don't bring anyone love into this no man
welcome welcome your mom's house
[Music]
cock bite hey cock bite you're not part
of ta staff are ya mm-hmm no he's not PR
staff PR RT public creations you know
part of the transsexual Oh adjustment
staff are you transgendered which turn
pronoun bro no no sorry fended are you
what yeah you just assumed my pronouns
sure I did really assume it when are we
going to see non-binary porn I can't
wait to see all that stuff the only
that's kind of course assuming of course
it's going to watch you pronoun I was on
Instagram you know I love Instagram
Instagram is my favorite song isn't it
the best it is I like photos I like you
know looking at a photo and deciding
like that's enough information for me
it's enough I like a nice caption a
photo I'm done I like it because you
really get insight into people's mental
illness it's not you know one thing I
saw the cursory that I realized is it's
fucking super weird to me hmm not weird
it's just I go hmm
hmm well I love cars you know I mean
I've always been in love with cars since
I was little boy I like playing with toy
cars or like car magazines I just love
cars yeah but you'll find somebody that
has you know a photo like I say I found
others guys in front of his car oh my
god beautiful car go to his page and his
page is nothing but him and his cars and
you're like it's it's just like it's too
much yeah and it's also like this guy
defines himself entirely by what he has
that's interesting
there's that that's so that's how the
guys do it yeah now the girls do the
body the girls do the well what's
interesting about the body thing is that
they take half-naked pictures what oh my
god what I got to show you I just got
this text what the bottom read the
bottom ah oh my god tonight oh my god
what do I do
uh I don't know love to figure this out
should we press pause I think so
all right I've got some exciting show
businesses for Tom which we can't reveal
yeah well I mean yeah I didn't mean to
be so dramatic obviously you all uh you
are basically it's I mean I can say this
it's just like I had an audition yeah
and they they want to see me again so
it's next level so that's awesome
and it's very exciting and will
everybody everybody cross your
sphincters for Tommy
cross cross your B holes it's all good
big excitement good good week for this
grouse lot going on yeah what were we
talking about before the surprise um
budge Oh
scamper snapples what were we talking
about we're talking about well we're
talking about the porno thing before the
break bodies bodies and then I played
this fucking guy so do you want to know
what that setup was for that yeah why
that guy was flipping out yeah so
apparently there was this uh this is
okay I'll tell you what that the thing
said here is that the guy there was an
incident occurred at the International
Longshore warehouse Union in Longview
Washington and reporters were there to
ask about a hostage situation that
happened weeks prior so six guards were
held hostage for a couple hours after
500 or more longshoremen broke down
gates and smashed windows in the guard
shack and this longshoreman is in no
mood to answer these questions so in
other words this is something that's
been like in the news and this news
reporter is just like hey I want to ask
again you know or ask more about the
incident that happened I think calls
macaque bite which is really funny I've
never heard that one alright is amazing
talk bites that's great well I loved it
you had that isolated already you knew
that was a winner Yeah right yeah so a
shark bite this is how the whole thing
unfolds this is the guy showing up the
news guy going like
like oh hi I'm with the kohai of you and
just wanted to know if there was anyone
here want to talk to us about the
situation from Black Sea
aha tell you how they're fucking the
longshoremen around here oh that's the
gentleman who gets more upset ant-man
I guess you see that the cameraman one
of them starts filming something that's
printed out hey here's your fucking
camera out of here that's none of your
fucking business you talk bite less you
a trespass you get the fuck out of here
now get it all so don't fuck with me
partner
you know the PR staff are you like it I
maintain a sense of humor
yeah our stuff are you oh yeah I also
think it's funny that the guy goes
unless you want trespassing like not if
you want to be charged with trespassing
hmm like unless you want robbery right
he just he he missed some conjugated no
well yeah under stress all right so
that's understandable I think he keeps
saying it you want trespassing but you
want something to drink
listen trespassing with you fucked out
here that's none of your fucking
business your cocksucker
let's go i trapped a fee did I hear
right you might be drunk we want your
fucking camera broke you cocksucker I
just wanted to hear yours I said by now
or you're going to get trespassing you
know you're gonna get trespassing you're
gonna get charged with treasure our each
other right or you you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna say you're
trespassing or you again you are trust
back you're gonna get trespassing is it
you're gonna get it
you're gonna get are going to give it to
them the trespassing you're going to
give you a shot at trespass look at the
shrimps yeah the shrimps and the
expressos all the shrimps the sperms and
the expresses are going to get you guys
messing and the liberry liberry you guys
have a library here doing a paper off
rip and we're leaving
fuck you art the cocksucker sit there
you know what you dumb motherfucker you
like your fucking glasses
don't fucking threaten me you son of a
bitch you worried my friend get the fuck
out of this Park you're not right baby
we'd like to go I mean later fellas
get out of here now give it why is this
guy fucking with him I like the UH
he has a great disposition though the
camera yeah
at least he's like I was doing this man
yeah he's done this a 500 times yeah
he's seen people lose their mom I don't
you feel like I don't you don't get to
hear people yell like this anymore you
know you don't really get to see it cock
bites and stuff I feel like I haven't
seen people freak out like this in -
yeah I miss it we just told these all
the time you're right yes exciting to me
yeah me too
cuz I like seeing people get upset like
that yeah yeah especially funny you know
this guy's he's upset because there is a
buildup of lasting this that you don't
get to see in other words you when
someone loses their mind it's not over
something reasonable right it's because
something builds up over time this guy's
been asked these questions for six weeks
it's the original trigger yes he's mad I
you know I have this guy he's mad at the
second yeah the first first hundred
reporters okay yeah this is pretty much
it so clean this is the exit edges I'm
not going to touch that cocksucker I
fucking coldcock him in a heartbeat
goodbye get out of fucking parking lot
fuck you you cocksucker
that's my name fuck you - cocksucker
yeah yeah I did get him down that's his
name
fuck you that's fucking cocksucker
that's my name I miss the shit yeah we
got to get more angry close again I
forgot how fun these are and if we could
go around the room and everybody just
state your name you cocksucker
alright hi fuck you you cocksucker talk
vice cardfight
and I miss the racist ones remember and
he's like you fuckin speck sorry huh
screaming over the fence that was a good
one I was great I wonder if it shocked
my pussy that was good we've been a
while that guy was uh our kiss my pussy
yeah not suck my pussy though
fuck it
mother
he's longshoremen I wouldn't fuck with
these guys well you know are you guys do
real work yeah and a real real fuckin
man well our old landlord one of our
past landlords was a longshoreman and he
was not he was a very gentle sweet guy
but he would tell stories of is a
co-worker's being gnarly dudes oh my
real gnarly real gnarly where I worser
shit just got white wash my I was at the
aeropuerto yesterday bright and early
and I was listening to people talk on
their phones and the rage inside of me
is kind of like that like the cock bite
rage where you're like what are you
doing asshole you know especially in
this era people feel okay about watching
videos on their phone at full volume in
public like who and nobody's correcting
this behavior but the phone
conversations insidious because you're
on the receiving end of one side of a
conversation yeah
and I think when it's way worse er is
when it's in a foreign language and now
I don't even understand what the fuck
you're saying and your language sounds
horrible to me and is it I think the
worst language I don't know what he was
I have been Vietnamese only because they
don't have volume control I know it's so
loud it's so I thought why do you know
that you're in public yeah why are you
fuckin it's it's and yelling in your
language it's listen we spoke Hungarian
growing up in my house but you know uh
yeah well this has speakerphone feedback
what we didn't do in public you speak
Hungarian because it's rude and it
excludes people yeah you know what I
mean you speak fucking English we would
probably yeah you know the the speaking
in another language in public because
you really have a secret that you're
excluding yeah
yes it's disrespectful to you know I see
this shit makes me oh no you got your
life okay your life in front of them do
I cop it right here right now stop it
yeah go on at the airport
yeah stop it yeah mmm-hmm yeah I know
and you're like do you like know what
this whole fucking no and it's never
about you know it's not it's not about
who won the Nobel Prize or you know
quantum theory it's always like we're
gonna meet you down at the baggage claim
all right okay well Susan gonna bring
the cake yeah she's going to bring the
cake like what are you doing it's total
like it is that some people have total
disregard for the world around them yeah
for other people Livius I don't even
know if the but I think some of it is
conscious I think it is conscious like
they say what they want you to hear what
they're talking about sometimes you feel
like it's uh something you know it's
like I important yeah you're standing
there and you're like huh yep
interesting none of us are sitting here
minding our own business that's the
thing that stands out is that everyone
literally everyone else in those
situations is considerate of everyone
else that's why that person stands out
you're the only one the only one doing
doesn't care dickbag
so now I what's your least favorite
language though let's get into that I'm
going to go with I don't like Russian I
have a bias so we all have biases right
I don't like Russian because culturally
that's my tribe ish they're my cousins
yeah
so that hard sounding Eastern Bloc shit
like I my shoulders go up around there
never by the way no connection doesn't
sound good to me I don't address it
fuck yeah Bosnia only a cure to be
really good oh yeah I like hearing I
stopped I had to pick like I don't mind
hearing the Romance languages it just
sounds so pretty yeah I mean Portuguese
oh come on let me go those are all like
when do you get to hear Portuguese and
pycelle them get you doing that but I'm
saying like it's not but when you hear
I'm headed I'm Alan two minute hammers
cocking you have me Holland cover that's
the one no and any language is ah that
uh anyway Israeli they do that in Farsi
all right go back to your fucking
country not that not it's not it's
irregardless its regardless I'm saying
yeah I don't give a sh I'm not talking
specific cultures don't care that's a
sounder language awful language yes
what's father's Nigerian doesn't sound
beautiful I'm not at all 10 then Arling
no no nice that's not nice you're
terrible
yeah but uh but I need it yes anything
I'll throw in yeah that somebody partly
naturally speaking English like that is
that's it why works is awful awful yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna get at the market
there's no onions and then you're like
Jesus dude
it's worse that you can understand it
cuz you're like your conversation is so
dumb so dumb
yeah so boring people just repeat the
same things to each other over and over
and some it is there's a split there are
people that are oblivious because you
can look at someone fuck are you doing
here like what I don't know and then
there's people that it's a what it is
it's it's a an attempt to show power
yeah because what you're saying is like
yes a moment where I can I'm going to
talk loudly yes in this I'm dominating
the space with my voice you assholes
have to hear what I'm talking about yeah
one time you and I were in a hotel we're
coming out of a nice restaurant and
there was a guy on his speakerphone I'm
a fear memory but we were getting a
valet we're waiting for the valet and
full full volume like hey could I put
that blah blah blah like something like
ivory coast's something and so I mean
actually I'll enjoyed him because I like
that accent yeah but
it's just you so loud yeah it's sowed
it's just soda but when you're tired and
you're in the airport you're like I
don't want to want to hear your fucking
I don't want to hear you bro
I agree a lot of uh basically I don't
want to hear your conversation yeah
area'd or your video or the music the
worst one time I was third out of their
mind
sitting next to a girl watching Korean
soap operas here's how easy Christ loud
some people are I'm on a plane a week
ago and a kid has his iPad or whatever
or some toy beautiful people and I'm
like hey I look over and then his parent
was like I don't forget that one
like was helping them yeah you're like
oh I can tell your kid to turn that down
or just give him headphones so ten
thoughts the rest of us don't have to
hear ppppp you it's obnoxious you are
obnoxious one time I was on a plane and
a guy was watching his movie but he had
his earbuds in
but the volume was pumping out full full
volume and it was a late night flight
and I'm I balling him eyeballing and
finally I go excuse me get could you
listen to that on your earphones and he
goes oh I thought I was I'm so sorry and
then he plugged it in that was a one
time I did actually see a person last
week do the same thing right I didn't
correctly what happened was a couple of
sitting next to each other and our war
started oh and you can hear it in the
cabin like dun dun dun time and I see
them going with the headphones they're
like and then and then I'll send the guy
yeah
we're not plugged in huh he said he
meant you know plugged in but that was
that's funny
different right like he's trying to
trying to be a civilized human people
are fucking psychos though it really is
to the advent of the cellular phone yeah
it's the iPhone etiquette we really
haven't we haven't figured out yet what
proper etiquette is for the phone yeah I
think that'll be hopefully in the next
few years people go alright at dinner it
shouldn't be on the fucking table yeah
there should be an iPhone etiquette
school or just societal norms that we
should all adhere to you from now on
agreed are you reading anything now by
the way Hellboy
I'm going to answer that that's a setup
but why is it or no sure of course it is
no it isn't I'm reading a book right now
read notice what is it read notice
there's a lot of pictures in there oh
yeah thank you
just reading it interesting uh-huh
what's that about it's about this guy
who his his grandfather started the
Communist Party a law and then he went
on it's a Russian basically real-life
thriller so it's my enemy
basically mm-hmm yeah but I feel about
the Russians so I'm in the part right
now where he's basically introducing how
he came to work he's a businessman but
in Eastern Europe oh very cool so I
didn't know you were interested in that
you should talk to my dad about that he
loves communist stuff yeah so but you're
not reading anything right now of course
I read stuff all the time but what are
you reading right now
ah it's called the something of the
gifted child the called the something of
the gifted child yeah I read a child
psychology book so I don't fuck up our
kid the drama of the gifted child this
lady has a review of that right here
okay here we go reading it oh shit she's
not even talking yet oh that's my
mistake okay here we go
you have footage of me reading yeah you
know I read Kindles I don't read them
pretty good review right um is that what
the doing out of the gifted child that's
the same thing do we get fart misters
calm I think we did laughing yeah I
think we need to start doing some with
it I'm surprised nobody had fart
mistress I know I'm really do you really
quit although it just goes to show that
the women doing the far
videos aren't that creative and that I
can really put a dent in that industry
why don't you really sell that to
somebody you know fart mistress I mean
to a real fart mistress I would love to
hey anyone out there want fart mistress
this one owns it I'll sell it to you for
a reasonable price
I mean wrong poof Wow that's her fart so
they're really good one really crazy
that's almost a stripper that's how my
mother spoke English when she first got
to the country yeah yeah like we call a
fan of monster I remember that Oh
monster yeah she's a monster because you
didn't know how to take man big monsters
make noise this lady said that her ass
is like a monster is pretty neat kind of
accurate now didn't you have quite a
brown day I'm so glad you brought that
up you may want to hit the all aboard
Brown taco I would get in ok alright I
didn't know that was coming hold on Nix
Doc Brown doc he went along so I went to
man Francisco this weekend thank you
everybody that came out to my shows they
were super fun it was really great I had
a lot of fun but a lot of mommies and so
anyways on Saturday I go have Thai food
by my hotel on the Embarcadero there and
I don't eat fucking honky food you know
I'm saying when I want flavor I get some
goddamn flavor especially San Francisco
I mean you have so many great choices in
San Francisco to had to like eat real
offense yeah I'd love the food there so
I go to this Thai place i order my pan
and curry and I was like you make that
shit spicy and don't make it fucking
white girl spicy like I want legit heat
on that bitch well I actually have a bit
in my act right now about that seriously
yes
seriously yeah yeah I'll tell you about
is it because I ordered that way at
Korean barbecue so much no no I demand
that they give me spicy so not a bit
about okay any whoodles I order it and I
ask for spicy and they bring it out and
I'm like oh shit like they really
it was too much but I couldn't send it
back because I demanded it you know what
I mean so I had to eat the dish anyways
and push through was it was hot as fuck
dude like they they didn't hold back on
me at all so I have to do this like I
can't have to save face so I eat it I
forget about it I'm fine and then
Showtime rolls around and the farts
begin and I had forgotten what I'd eaten
earlier I was like why these farts here
you know when you do that where you kind
of her like I'm farting but I'm not sure
why and then it occurred to me I had
that Thai food and it was like mystery
solved so I sit down to make brown and
I'm having so many pain it's so much
pain because the farts are really
violent like hard farts and I fucking
I'm shitting I'm shitting and it's show
time now I'm getting I'm getting text
messages from the club like hey they
show that 7:30 you know that remark yeah
and I'm in my show outfit like tights
dress and I'm like I'm shitting and it's
bad and it's like a multi wiper and I
don't have time to go shit the shower
because it's show time like I pay our
key I just have to keep rub rub rub wipe
swipe swipe swipe
Neverending wipe there's I've leaky but
there's so much toilet paper in the bowl
there's so much Brown in the bowl it was
so painful and then so I flush and I'm
like Cole went down and then the water
rises you do good and it starts to spill
a little little little and then
miraculously
it slowly goes back down so it goes
under when you told me that things she
was turds on the ground
Loretta and reminded me yes Jacksonville
that's right that's where tours about
the comedy zone and that's where I had
turds on the ground and I had to tell
the hotel staff that there were turds on
yeah
[Music]
yeah around and everywhere what a
classic dance yeah like my jam on the
ground yeah yeah I got
Tipler made that it was really good so I
got really close to turds on the ground
but no turrets on the ground at San
Francisco but it was close dude tariff
was bad and I like I said it was just
like a leaky but situation all night I
kept wiping it was terrible yeah do you
get that - I forget what where you doing
never-ending wipe we're like you just
keep wiping all the whole thing that's
so upsetting you know that brings up
this actually came in you brought this
up right now isn't bed look this email
came in swear to God how do blind people
know to stop waving hey Hitler's I've
been a big fan of show since mommy Tina
was in fart NICs a few months ago I've
been binge listening
40 plus hours a week or he pries
something every second of it
I'm not all the way through but I've
always wanted to know one thing I
believe you're the people help me find
out how do blind people know when
develop wipe they don't
how have we gone this long without
knowing this age-old question thank you
for everything you do look forward to
the next time you are in fart Nicks oh
you got see this is funniest thing we've
never discussed I feel like we may have
discussed it feels familiar I really do
think we discuss if I think it's a long
time
how how do you pay now they I asked one
time they wipe a bunch yeah and then
they do a bare hand wipe and they smell
wait I know what they have a dog
do it again saying eye dog hell no no
it's a reasonable question I think even
dog sniffs your be hones is brown I
think you know I think you just get a
sense of it just like a seal because
you're so cool you're so tied to your
vision helping your senses eventually
like I think what happens it becomes
intuitive and they just go I'm done now
that's a good theory well if you're
blind I guess have someone write in for
us for you or you could write in how do
they do it they don't think it you don't
write either they don't type in the
email sure they do and they have Braille
keyboard time oh yeah okay so use your
Braille keyboard
yeah and like let us know let us know
how you white guy like mysteries and
tell us about the learning curve tell us
about bad you know times you guessed
wrong don't just be like yeah of course
I know how to do it tell us to give us a
little insight
yeah we're dumb know these things see
this is so this is so important the work
we're doing on your mom's house like
don't know when I asked if retarded
people knew they're retarded and now
we're going to find out if blind people
know how they're done wiping it's pretty
really we're really helping Society we
are helping a lot we haven't yet
mentioned that pretty soon we're going
to be joined by a guest today mr.
Aristotle Schaffer is coming in is it
really short for Aristotle no not his
name definitely not no no Marisol wasn't
Jewish no no Greek yeah it's a Greek
name I know that I feel like I have more
thoughts on this blind wiping situation
though yeah okay we get any more
opinions are you saying you can't stop
thinking about it
I feel like that's a wild okay oh here's
what I was going to say because
sometimes Browns are misleading like the
other week I had what I thought would be
a disastrous cleanup you know like it
was hot and I was like oh this is going
to be a nightmare and I went to wipin
the paper was totally clean yeah so it's
like it's not it's just not I assure a
science you know yeah
who are you texting arey what's he doing
just letting him know to be on time I
don't know I hate when people are late
me too oh my god I just
okay you know what I thought was funny
and man friend disco the women were
talking about because when I lived there
in the 90s it was hard to find a
boyfriend because all the dudes are gay
now another not now they're not all gay
now they're all nerds yeah I hear
because of the tech industry moving up
there that there's a lot more straight
guys but that they're all socially not
adept yeah oh they're all dorks big old
dorks
yeah the whole tech industry has moved
into that area it completely changes
also priced out basically the whole city
oh yeah it's terrible it must be it was
hard when I was living there now it's
got to be why would I ever want to move
to another city though yeah the thing
yeah but then I go not LA like I just
remember it's not LA right and then I go
back here don't you ever want to live in
a city city again though or no not with
a kid I think it's just you're rid of
them
here's a part about SF is that just
getting groceries you don't have a car
there because it's so hard to have a car
there's no parking you still want to
live on the ocean though right ocean
least you want to go Beach 100% you love
Moran key I would live in Marin Marin
County yeah across the the Golden Gate
Bridge there that are here in LA County
you live anywhere Beach beach side
anywhere Mountain maribou yeah palisade
Palisades I nodded Vanek at Santa Monica
Montes Santino
Redondo Venus Manhattan's for Denali man
hands with - bro e sometimes for me it
bros down her most is actually the mo
bro that's too brilliant for life yeah
give me the fucking thing bro yeah but
now I like more seclusion I don't like
as many people at Alice Verdes yeah I
love tells her to go far though right
now where it is you know yeah on
Oxnard's too far north
I know the most desirable places are the
ones here and they're so expensive
I know Kai tell you where I want us to
retire though we're Maui Maui
we're all like the the nut bet like the
Wayne Dyer's the Doreen Virtue is all
these nut bags that I like yeah like
where all the meditation retreats are
with romnod America intimately I've
never been there either but I feel like
you and I would really enjoy it bro down
I think you know I would really dig
Hawaii is like a retirement I want not
only went to lanai yeah that was crazy
fun look yeah it was but I wouldn't live
there because there's only like 3,000
people on that I know I don't want to
live on an IE too small but now we
thought that we've got it going on it's
pretty except I can eat snack adamian
nuts every day because they're there
that's that's where they come from roll
out of the ground they're there you just
walk around and there's macadamia nut
and every apples people just go join a
glass of pineapple and they just give
you a pineapple that's right guy you're
so smart you're so smart
can we talk about our dad day yeah and
my Smurf day is okay yesterday you Sir
Paul McCartney yep my niece Grayson yep
some other kid was it Bella Rossellini
all had birthdays yeah yeah Sir Paul
McCartney that's what he likes me to
call him and Sir Paul and I spent the
morning stuck on a plane I woke up I
slept for three hours is fun and but you
got me this gorgeous ring yeah it's
really outstanding going to wear it on
my special job right you did a wonderful
job you don't know when you buy jewelry
for someone you like did I do well I
don't know until they actually you can
tell by the reaction you were like what
you know why because I'm so Eastern Bloc
that I immediately think how much did
you pay for this I don't deserve this I
don't want to wear something expensive
well I gave a better of cars where Ellis
is college yeah well we spend it wisely
yes well I get I you know anything to go
to Yale for four years or do you want a
ring that's what I decided on I know I
just get weird about jewel jewelry it's
a nice ring jewelry that's how you say
it not jewellery you know true jewelry
was free I want in a contest you did I'd
you get this the shootin hoops
oh geez soon well then so you got me the
super nice ring and you got me some PJ's
I did good lad you're always like
talking about PJs and you put your PJs
on it
oMG ever I'm not really a PJ guy no I
like boxers and I've tried buying you
them every year is one of those things
do you ever have things where you go you
imagine you want to be that thing yeah
then you know I mean like yeah I'm the
same way with robes basically yeah I see
someone in a robe I'm like I want that
room yeah and then I get a robe and I
use it twice I know I lose it I forget
where it is my house with PJs I see
someone in it and like in a catalog
wearing their pigeon like I looks so
comfortable I like sleeping in boxers I
feel about high heels like I'll buy a
pair I wear them once oh yeah right the
exception for the PJs thing is sometimes
they make like sleep shorts or the real
loose baggy the dick short shorts yeah
yeah I like those too sleeping yeah I
don't like an actual pajama ensemble you
know I don't wear it well that's a
little corny for guys some guys are into
it yeah all those guys are I'm not
buying you a word for those yes they're
definitely challenging the
intersectional narratives if you know
what I mean I read about two thing I
read that on hipster countries it's just
like the gays somebody this orange is
the new black actress is non-binary and
somebody real number yeah she really is
out and she's good really hey um hi how
are you what's your name what did you
pronoun you're gonna die you're gonna
die look can I read you what she wrote
today shit her name is a age' Kate Dylan
she's one of the white girl white
supremacist character tell me your name
again
Asia ASI asi
Kate Dylan okay and she plays one of the
like I said one of the white supremacist
girls on orange is the new black so she
wrote I think people received my message
of being non-binary and feeling really
pretty and she's a great actress
I received my message of being
non-binary and viewing gender identity
as a spectrum better because I'm white
was assigned female at birth and on a
super popular television show aja
answers honestly my friends who were
assigned male at Birth people of color
particularly those who identifies them
have an incredibly hard time they are
ostracized and there are very few safe
spaces for them I'm grateful for my
visibility and the conversations that
are happening
and I just I like the comment so someone
Thank You Asia for complicating the
narrative and keeping it intersectional
I don't know that my sesame knew that I
love it oh wait okay so she's on this
new show she's the new non-binary are
billions on billions yeah she's on she
were calling her a she and we don't know
if that's her preferred pronoun but you
said her again to shit but this person
is on both shows yes on billions and oh
yeah she's killing it they are darling
sorry they're killing it this other
person writes there's also living in a
country where the language doesn't
gender neutral pronouns so you have to
invent them and that makes it harder for
people to understand alright so what
else you got another thing John anything
happening I don't know why I makes me
laugh so hard I know God love them the
God help these people
remember that kid he's just crying Oh
poopie kisses memory you wanted me to
bring back poopie kisses yeah I made a
note of it cuz we good yeah you said to
me the other day why we got to bring
back poopie kiss that's a nice way to
spin so you're farting yeah you're
farting mmm poopie gives the poopie kiss
for your face I feel like I need to call
airy colors I don't know let me see
because he doesn't understand well he
doesn't like text like a normal person
he has like a flip phone yeah he's so
weird yeah super annoying huh yes I was
joking with me
he's a little liner oh he's here let's
stop for a second let's go get him let's
challenge for alright yeah we had to we
had to but we mentioned it earlier but
it's official it's now a thing it's here
[Music]
our guest has arrived you Jew
motherfucker you Aristotle Schaffer
so welcome ariari is that he's Mike
you're not Mike that on sorry sorry hold
on hold on hold on hold on give me a
second give me a second um wait a minute
no no how about now
yeah work oh yeah I was just kidding
yourself that's beautiful thank you no
we got it work though is Ari uh Hebrew
for like can I get a discount what does
that actually mean
what is it exactly I hope a blogger is
reading this just go to town Oh
I will no blogger ever defend the Jews
now what is Airy short for it I'm sorry
it is for our yeah our Arielle a yahoo
aria it means Aria means a lion in
Hebrew boy a lion yeah Wow my hair
way more resemblance yeah unless your
men have crazy hair yeah we're good
right it was great great hair I remember
that see people now that bushy fuck you
know ya ball and my god damn yeah what's
your middle name David in English and in
Hebrew sorry yeah oh yeah who are there
but nothing who are you David if you ask
any Jew if their name is not David if
you were like what's your middle name
just guess David yeah and by the waves
are this always makes me crazy when
people are as guests on podcast
including when I've been guests on
podcast yeah and it's like hey I have
something and then we don't address it
forever it offsetting at least once
right out of the gate let's mention that
on July 9 18 18 18
Ari Shaffir has a murmur Netflix special
hmm set it called
I'll take those two pennies and it's
coming out it's double actually what
else that would be a good name for the
special I'll take those two pennies this
is a double session I would actually
work I didn't figure it is a double
special about it does it work like the
way Chappelle's does where it's like a
collection and my
one place yeah but repels are like I
don't know why they did it like that
they're unrelated completely but that is
like that yours is actually two separate
things we'll play yeah yeah Wow do
that's incredible yeah I really
envisioned it that way that's not
douchey but I'll get to finish a special
yeah start number two start over to take
a break
unreal man and they so I understand so
you'll film a year apart or simultaneous
I felt like some attached so I had I did
at cap city and uh I changed clothing I
finished it thank you good night and
then they clapped and I was like hey
don't go anywhere
I forgot like a shitload left and then I
changed clothes on stage he change the
scattered off changes set up we left
because I wanted to have a similar look
so I change it to like the lighting so
it's like distressed wood background and
I change the backlighting and the
foreground lighting I flipped them for
the second one and I just went close
interesting it's a little different I
know but like well you tell them the
kind of the concept yeah half of its
about children my feelings of its or you
guys are kids cute but ya know for me
yeah right I figured that out yeah it's
not exactly administration why would you
let me touch them no germs or man I
don't like to encourage stranger strange
men going natural good boundary in other
words yeah some kids I was age somebody
goes like hey like that and they run up
and hug them I discourage that now are
anyway our kid doesn't distrust people
oh yeah yeah remark are you looking for
me yeah yeah great yeah I as you know
have contacts at Netflix and I reached
out and was able to obtain a clip oh
well yeah so here's a little taste that
a big Jews with the Western wanna know
it's not okay fucking doing I fucking
know
[Laughter]
this is not even Orthodox Bar Mitzvah is
a woman doing it on a lot of my
operating terrible now wild more about
your upbringing later we are the
children that not having care your
feelings about children is one and then
what's the other thing is about
adulthood so it's just I give it up for
kids a little bit yeah I understand
small parts of them but then the other
side is like a life where you really
just can't have if you have like a wife
and kids yeah
what can I give you a perfect example
yes that like it just shows you kind of
different thoughts yeah you I'm going to
New York yeah and you're like why aren't
you staying for like a few days yeah
right and it's the it's a normal thought
for a single guy there doesn't have a
family
New York City but like any guy with the
family would be like what do you time
yeah why would I stay there for a few
days I actually lived most of my life -
you said it once where it's like oh man
I wish I could do it I think was I moved
to New York like I wish I could do that
Mike why don't you like I'm married can
do and I was like oh yeah yeah I mean I
wish I could do it in the sense it's
like I go wish I could fucking go
parasailing tomorrow - right right like
it's an enjoyable kind of like oh that's
cool you get to but I'm not going to do
that yeah you know well there's you know
it's funny when I think about Ellis
there's only a couple of real things
like I don't like about having a kid
like and this is so stupid but I don't
like not sleeping as much as we used to
or sleeping in that part of motherhood
is the only thing that really bought a
phone number one I covered that in a
special yeah that tiredness that all you
guys that perfect but it I mean then you
wait against the other thing called
ambivalence where you're able to
simultaneously have contradictory
feelings I learned about the sincerity
not everything is black and white right
I didn't know that until I had a kid
things are not and most people are not
black right we tried to make everybody
black and like that guy sucks he's great
really please don't forget charity yeah
but it kills minds like I know what the
charity still work of course yeah
most people are complicated right it's
all but I also want to go to Fiji and
that we're going to have to put off
right and that's something we just can't
literally do why don't you are oh and
I'm parented I'm not selling out a
parent your kid likes why don't you
leave a bunch of food in a bowl
like I don't that's a good point not
cover up the sockets with a little guys
over all righty
teaching resilience self-sufficiency now
your upbringing
you are Orthodox Jews we know now did
your mom wear a wig like is it that
worth about yeah yeah my sister wears
away all the time my mom would generally
wear like a hat except like High
Holidays and that you were wicked I had
it I think I wonder if she had none of
it anymore
have you seen her natural like are you
like yeah I brought the home she's fine
and what was she a blonde or something
naturally she's been dyeing her hair for
so long I think she's great naturally is
that possible no yeah I think she's
blonde
yeah no crazy yeah yeah you think I
should take the 10:10 p.m. flight or the
11:15 p.m. place
don't Oh what time you trying to get in
that's the thing they get in about an
hour apart either 6:45 or 7:40 can you
check into your local traffic where you
going to oh yeah you love whatever you
can suck up and murder okay dude took me
now I have to get to my hotel when I did
Gotham oh it's just really not compute
so I know why there's no good subway
system I know why it's a cabs unions
they want to allow the subway to go over
there anyway my child so if you think
it's rooted in your did you hate your
childhood is that why I loved it I loved
it seriously yeah Kyle is the best
pretty public about our hands I oh yeah
I didn't look crazy mom it was their way
of it not trying to commit suicide in
front of me oh yeah yeah
no but continuing because you think that
somebody with my background because I
used to be like that to where I was
afraid of I don't want a family I didn't
really think I would end up married okay
but now that I have it I love it because
I wrote the stability and this you find
us with most people oh right
I have kids they're like guys what I
like yeah so what like where what was a
defining moment for you where you're
like I know I thought for me I think
it's more reason where I was like for a
while I was like of course a lot of kids
it's you supposed to do yeah you're 22
like I've lost my religion and it was
like and I moved out here 25 and then I
ask you this when we told me one time
about no no about stopping the religious
thing how much you research that
bullshit I wrote I clip real quick okay
go ahead so I was it a lightbulb moment
what what what that like abandoning
religion was it like a
one like you like dates back to it to a
thing it took me like a year like ponder
in my head until I realized like oh but
you really did ponder for a while then
yeah and what was the Epiphany was it
that God doesn't exist or that this
particular system of religion is not it
was and I don't have a belief in it the
I first I was agnostic I was like I
don't know it came it was sleeping in a
dorm near Shiva in Israel and we hit a
light bulb over the beds for reading and
you could like twist it up and I
remember this I do you see this is the
story yeah yeah you could put a cup on
top of it so Jonathan Lyte so the cool I
can sleep but then the cup kept like
sliding off because is like circular
frame to it and he she kept sliding off
as like maybe just turn the light off
but my door was like my window was like
right by the entrance to the dorm so I'm
like people going to see if I turn my
light off and it's everyone's like
religious Jewish you can't do it I'm
Friday night oh sorry but you weren't
allowed to have a nice gift for carries
electricity bit yeah you can leave it on
all the whole time or you can turn it
off the whole time
oh go on can't go one or these so
drowning it out is okay still are not
changing the spark this is such weird
shit but like that odd a distinction to
make yeah it's funny too how many of
those things are like tied to a practice
and they become symbolic but but but
their actual origin is not something
like no it's not like like I'm saying
like with food eating let's say like
people stay away
I don't know from certain foods but the
origin of that was like a practical
thing you know right they would say yeah
like something like some foods wouldn't
you know hold well for certain people
get sick so they go we don't eat that
and then years later they don't get sick
that other thing is not either yeah yeah
why like you did they become symbolic
I'm just eating nothing I was always so
the reason we don't eat stuff is not
sort of like tapeworm or anything yes
because God said oh well never mind no
practical reason but that's probably if
God was invented that's probably what
one of the things is so so wait so we're
in his epiphany though I don't know yeah
okay so the thing would stay on I kept
taking like I'll just turn my light off
I just turn it off what you're not
allowed to do but I was I can get it
caught and then I thought about it later
where's like Who am I worried about
getting caught by right man or God right
and if I really believed in God who
didn't
want me to do that then I'm saying
wouldn't be a question you don't do that
yeah so how's that why am i questioning
it and it finally came to like I don't
think I believe in God yeah I don't
think it's in me and then once I figure
that out I was like I think I should
stop I went to talk about you turn that
light off huh where were you fucking CP
University in New York and like uh
Spanish Harlem 180 seconds ago you went
to Taco Bell I want to talk about I
bought yeah what did you order what was
the honorary tacos for fucking $1 I put
up her too
I don't know because the shitty food or
guilt I'm not really sir we've been such
big fans with Neil Hamburg yeah I'm so
glad you're bringing this up set up uh
what up right now Neil hamburgers yeah
is he starting a chain
kamil hand idea you know him right oh so
funny his Twitter feed is great oh
really he does this yeah semi-regularly
um where i want to talk about this brown
i had yeah make i know let's not let's
not lose track of his uh his story here
either but I have to just mention it I
love him to get so much stuff going on
you gotta like yeah right now so he
finds people's tweets
yeah about getting some Taco Bell really
and research there's a lot of them oh my
god like it's constantly go ahead read
it out loud with you I want to talk
about want to talk about left I had it I
looked at the Taco Bell I work I got
mice and bugs all over their place this
thick of fuck a nigger gets food
poisoning from talk about cuz I know
that means because or cousin okay
I did a presentation today I'm back on a
bacteria causes food poisoning I think I
got food wiser to talk about ironic as
fuck talk about getting read to cover
talk about talk about for the people who
say goodbye graduation I never use a
wheel is broken well it's all food and
learn it's a cutter all my 44 yeah these
are all my cardboard dude and he does
this every few months
Wow one day it was like isolated over
three years
my J found a roach on my food and I went
back they also wrote shit I'm a taco
bell I'm a cart had a whole side ass
ratchet chilled all of it so the talk
about diarrhea thing is true all right
here I go
Taco Bell three years ago what's a Los
Lunas New Mexico talk about found a hair
on our dock today
Thunder hair on our food before we close
yeah oh my friend got ya so and went to
the hospital went again the next day and
got bad believe it I can't believe it
Taco Bell never fails to give me food
poisoning your nasty-ass food
establishment gave me food poisoning as
well never again to just search food the
worst food poisoning a problem I think I
think you said sisters taco let's talk
about that oh yeah three different times
okay creation I done went I so I want to
talk about if I guess a Mount Vernon and
I done got boys I go some shit like God
bro really be shitting yeah I am crazed
on that account
Oh Faneca I chose her I lost my heart
but isn't the amount of them astounding
like many people who are this is
countless well I you know the meat is
supposedly supposedly worse than
president about this blessed one here
I mean Taco Bell again that shit has a
nigga stick well XS I don't care for
your choice of words but it's a
sentiment I can oh damn
that's right yeah I love what I could
come up like that just centers on
something I did you ever see Colin
Quinn's like tongue in cheek like uber
conservative tweets
yes Oh his Twitter account never never
lets her and I'm joking never know that
would be like yes it's party you have to
like really accept that that that
there's many people out there that
believe that you're serious yeah I think
that's a real struggle for like a lot of
comics and I think that he is so sure of
everyone yes that he fully goes for it
also if you don't fool people
quite as fun exactly Eddie Kaufman how
to get people like at the back on stage
or do it
I like his serious stuff like there's
just nothing like hearing laughter out
it is a human power of laughter
like how last week like I said yeah yeah
now that's a smart move because we would
have done that with Rogen what see
instead of covering about each other
covering your phone oh I think that that
might be true I don't think it's made
for that exactly a mom summit for those
hey dude what are you doing sorry your
mom is made for hooking up my microphone
Hanks well she anyway area I'm glad
you're here because you and I we share a
common bond that we both love to shit
and shower yeah every time I mention it
people like Oh Chris do you know Mike
yeah I guess we drop a BA kindred
poohbear really are yeah really oh we
got this bidet toilet fast you go
straight to the shower you save money on
toilet paper first of all that's not the
point but it is a definite thing
second of all it's the cleanest you can
get if the cleanest you know drawing
your drawing now what led you to shit to
shower I want to talk about your
experience I believe the first time was
kind of like my Epiphany with Judaism
where just like it just sort of happens
you know I was tied no toilet paper
oh I looked under this book sink like I
did yeah
I think this at my old place on Sunset I
just think I was like Nanak fuck what am
I gonna do huh and then it hit me
straight to shower straight yeah that's
interesting because necessity is the
mother of invention is now with me it
was that I have what is known as the
never-ending wife I get leaky but where
I Wi-Fi Wi-Fi wipe and the papers always
brown and I found that the only way the
Lord of it I would man stop the breath
is if I shower my butthole then the
brown stops coming down you get like
greasy greasy leak really solid brown no
no it's like a mush just like a like a
smear oh yeah like I don't know I don't
know what that is
uh-huh like a sun-dried tomato cream
cheese yeah but anyway we got this new
toilet this robot toilet that those are
great it's a wash lead it's a bidet in
your turn
and you don't have to go into the shower
physically because some of that's
annoying like I want take my pants off
yeah I'll dry off this thing though
missing what's amazing is you have
different water pressure options Oh
oscillating pulsating options what do
you mean water temperature options yeah
cold warm hot yep it's pretty amazing so
basically you can you're done yeah you
have a nice stream to kind of start kind
of get your asshole agenda yeah and then
you can fucking gas it up and have a
fire Wow and really get finally that you
can beat you can let that thing run for
a minute put toilet paper back there
nothing clean as a West yet and there's
a dryer Kappa will explain this me once
about wet wet wipe egg as opposed to dry
wet
you know what though I find what I said
effective I don't think that's enough
well just in general using water yeah
right yeah he said he's no I just use
total Cavey is back that and he was
thought ID cash Tito there yeah and he
was like look and he took some a little
bit of coca-cola yeah put it on my table
and then he goes okay let that sit for a
minute I wipe it up with a dry towel and
now seal the table I'm like hey a little
sticky goes yeah a little sticky
yeah Yeah right in water I didn't know
that he was such an expert we have
further questions for REM so fascinating
yeah why not talk about Southeast Asia
toilet but oh I can't okay wait we'll
save it wait wait why been dying to talk
to you about this okay so now when you
do shit to shower in your world use you
a cursory wipe an exploratory wipe or
you literally dump your shit straight to
shower without even a cursory wipe okay
I'm going to ask you of your opinion
later wouldn't you do okay occasionally
I'll go nothing but he doesn't really
I'll do matters no wife because it's
like what did you drip on the way
depends on by the bath mat there you
have it I don't want to ruin a bath mat
full dump
hold up just stand up and go in the
shower well I can reach over from the
toward I turn the hot water on other
place is a little harder but yeah just
so full I think you get to watch all the
shit run down this to sink like in
psycho remember in psycho what she's
bleeding out and I'm so drain blood yeah
you got that you guys have run down your
leg which is all usually horrible but
it's not going to stick right your
shower
do you do okay now because that to me is
a little bold Otis not all the time
sacrament and I do live with someone so
I try to be considered I wouldn't put
Duke even rewards on the bathroom he's
going to shower they're after me and I
don't want shit in our shower really so
I do an exploratory consideration wipe
now sometimes I have just known like
that wasn't a massive brown there's not
there's nothing on my asshole that was a
clean break
[Music]
alright I feel yeah it's good this is
the ticket to go to the journalists
right again or even about white again I
was like seven skew but uh yeah I'll
only go if I'm confident that there's no
brown on my butthole I will just go
straight to shower if I'm confident and
then sometimes I am never bleed out of
my vagina
yeah alright yeah that's normal yeah you
are you still bleeding out of your
asshole not through my whole trip in
Southeast Asia when I got back like the
second day was full-blood ago no
drippers really talk about this what do
you do you think that I mean internal
hemorrhoid ask the doctor there's like
you're good that does Bloods too dark
you see this in Asia so far yeah loot I
don't know it's just why should any
other silly place blue the other people
oh holy shit other two seem shocked or
animated flute was her regime why did
you do that could you push out air that
way no I've never been able to qui font
command no okay
he's loving it laughs he's like what the
that's a real talent though yeah also
playing a tune I'm just blowing out
anyway he's also hitting beep that's
right on it's a real skill anything like
that you seen ah last time I went to
Thailand like two years ago he puts a
pop on the street in Thailand at with
these katie's women that Bangkok
yeah Bangkok they gave you a rolled-up
piece of uh well first I gave you a
balloon hold it above your head and
you're like
and then they shoot darts out of Aegina
to pop your balloon Wow
then you applaud for that ice oh yeah
it's not sexual at all it's just talents
it's not sexual
then you roll up a piece of paper into a
funnel hold that over your head what are
you doing and then they start peeling
bananas and you're like no no shoo
bananas out and get it into a little cup
you've made impossible what's the trick
what's the there's there's got to be a
circus trick there Roger
no Carnegie Hall that can't be legit no
way man that you think that's real out
of there Jeremy out I've seen I'm gonna
see too many of them yes pops out oh I
don't have a giant I don't know wow we
have to be able to suck air in before
you put the object in because I've seen
girls that can queef on command I've had
friends that can do it yeah and you lay
on your back and you suck in the air I
don't know mate that that did that was
asshole really yeah yeah sure doubt
stuff
no no just the air thing but on like he
would just get on he could do it on all
fours lay on his back and just all day
he goes really yeah wow what a town what
a superhero it was really cool yeah yeah
I wonder if I have like a wrestling
style school for that for shooting
somebody or vagina it's like not ready
yet but I want to get my accreditation
do this so let's talk about the toilets
in Asia okay so they have these if
they're not squat toilets I hate those
yeah they're pretty bad and I hear that
it's better for you blah blah yeah I
love how much Revis committed to remove
ourselves some people actually hiring us
we just do stuff like that okay all
right no apology necessary to local yeah
somebody yeah I was an Asian person
saying it so yeah it's not impressive
yeah chong ching chong um they're just
gonna have directions who knows so they
have the squatters that's why I hate
yeah a lot of times oh they have toilets
and hostels without their toilets but
that these bum guns which is just like
you know I want to sink you'll get like
the thing you get to pull out yeah we
have that yeah but without the what's it
called the spray
yeah so it's just a stream and you put
that into your but Georgia but you just
spray it out and then like you said get
that one wife but it's almost clean did
you like that did you prefer that to the
whole tower
yeah you can't throw out I got used to
it no shit showers the best but you
can't throw out your toilet paper in the
toilet right they also love to go in the
trash can I file is shit it smells
horrible I use words one of my good
friend is married a woman from chaotic
Oh oh my god Emily came they were throw
stuff out the trash cans toilet paper
like but like I used toilet paper toilet
paper as you guys don't have a bomb guns
like oh yeah so this is the stern ass
big wads of shit ah like they're getting
one last wife they're doing a whole
thing here and he was like I'm not doing
this and they just don't know habitual
we're talking like they're 40 years of
doing this yeah right like what
sometimes yeah you bet Wow
yeah that's that's the opposite of that
in those hospitals like hey I know used
to where you are and you can't flush
clothes in there yeah uh hey I had a
question oh hey we had an email today
how do blind people know when to stop
wiping what are your thoughts on that
taste test okay their sense of taste is
higher than most people yeah yeah yeah
oh I really thought it was a thing where
they eventually do a bare hand thing and
then they just go oh there's nothing
there yeah maybe but they'd have to like
they couldn't go like half like go on
how close I am right right like you look
at toilet paper when you're out you
don't have a shower you look at it you
like okay about halfway there you look
like recorders the way there yeah it's
true you don't just keep going it's like
this feel no I've been way down
right right right maybe maybe you smell
the toilet paper why you have to smell
your bare hand oh I think in rail that's
a great tweak what you just did right
stepped up a great right right wait what
you saying because I'm an observational
person that you wide whities why do they
have to smell their bare hand like you
said why not smell the toilet paper
oh I see so now I know because one of
them told me that's what they do
really oh so I got this for you I wish I
could park with a Ryan O'Neal yeah and
uh I mean tell me where Griffith Park
someone she's walking around we're
talking okay at a
ten minutes in I was like fine shit this
morning I have to shake haha he's like
really Mike ah hold it hold it
three more minutes like I'm not holding
it man I gotta go he's like how you
gonna wipe I'm like well he had a full
bottle of water I'm like with that he
said what do you what what do you mean
no don't do this and I was like yeah I
had the sports top no ah what edge is
just kind of like one of these yeah
Arrowhead bottle and then uh shit on a
hill so really squat shot which I'm used
to now I've got experience you get away
from people ya got it out and down the
hill little bit cut to it got to like a
big bunch behind me so people are on the
road I'm happy you're way down and you
looked up you could for sure see a manic
water if I was homeless I'd have a shirt
on yeah yeah let's talk about the
squatting technique because I imagine
what's problematic is that you might
shit on your jeans absolutely
so how do you learn to lean backwards
there's also I pulled your jeans forward
yeah yeah demonstrate make sure to get
this on yeah okay I don't know I want to
watch everything your pants down I mean
your your underwear down yeah I don't
need to see that pretty much get the
idea can we go around the corner they're
good people
okay sorry got his pants down right now
he's got some mushroom boxer shorts on
and he's standing and so uh yeah dude
all right pulled his pants down and his
underwear Dan please put them back on
for the love of dogs in here okay he's
showing I guess because of you
please don't play your pencil is assumed
that okay so you don't want to shit he
just wanting be right into the pan he's
squatting but you're squatting straight
so everything's at a perfect angle okay
so you're hanging answer no okay so
you're really just cuter you squat back
a little bit you're Scottish walk you
squat full she wants back my balls right
Tom touching the toilet is a real issue
like big long balls that's an issue but
I was on a hill and rivet Park no big
deal right now when you are doing that
at Griffith Park what
about the weeds and the brush touching
your dick in your balls in your butthole
and all that dried leaves definitely
touched ya didn't care for it so you're
saying it's all about the lien like what
you kind of did the way you are
squatting is how I've seen like Chinese
guys smoking in Chinatown yeah they're
used to it they always sit like that
yeah yeah this tougher goal hold back
squats up with um tan you both are so
big so very so then I pour water in my
hand immediately as it's wet took it to
the but it kind of wiped oh you think
you did it with your hands
yeah and then got more water wipe more
water wife no didn't dig in with nails
didn't want anything my nails ma'am and
then I was forced by Ryan to wipe my
hands in dirt afterwards okay and then
you wash your hands later I'm hoping
yeah how much like do you get a lot of
ball attention when you're with like are
they like oh these are great balls like
you should be the big thing couple times
yeah I've had a couple girls going man I
love these balls
really but like twice now are you really
into your own balls then like is that a
big like if you're making your list
you're like definitely like play my
balls I think immediately they're good
weapons yeah how saggy they are yeah I
mean if there were nice tight ones it
wouldn't be as funny but I really well
is it really a turn-on saying like if if
you were like if a woman was like what
what do you like what we're about to
have sex we like definitely play my
balls no not okay so now like your thing
I don't mind it it's kind of nice
actually but it's not like I need that
it's not you need it no not at all you I
mean I like it but I mean it's not like
I wouldn't be like if you don't play my
balls we had a problem jailbreaker how
big were re balls they just live like I
am NOT look what it looks like there was
like six balls the left would hang about
like a like a half matted pizza dough
kind of thing I was just like I think we
already didn't look too hairy down there
a glimpse kind of like a teenager's
beard occasionally you do a lot trimming
or no nothing really
zip oh my god I got to do a lot of that
really why Georgia linear no no
Argentinian what are you getting at
Peruvian Peruvian yeah and I you know
whatever but um it's a lot I don't know
it's a lot of hair I'm not like actually
I have one of my friends do you like it
him fall down they're not bald I like a
good clean up I think that it's
to at least be a little hygienic yeah I
don't like so much hair that it's
annoying it too much
yeah it can get away from you you know
yeah it stops growing at some point
though yeah it does but yeah I look down
there my proof yeah
I mean I just need like a haircut you
don't want to talk yeah no nuts grows
and then it's to Velcro II when it's too
long sometimes look like the head just
like peeking out of the woods you know
like my dick just heard something like
what's going on like Groundhog Day you
know that if you without a few weeks of
wheel back in yeah so your polyps is
that what you have polyps is that in
your butthole you said you have
hemorrhoids remember next time I go and
can you do something to stop them from
oh no he said I could have surgeries is
not worth it
Kathy's like it might not work and it's
just like invasive and you've never have
you ever seen gieux clam excuse me are
you gonna show I don't know I know no I
don't know right now I can't do it
doesn't sound good really it's so bad I
thought in person I was like are you
there wouldn't happen
dude I was in a capsid I was in cap city
yeah I'll try to really put that video
out some of my special you know I gotta
saw it and I remember that I pulled I
was so traumatized that I pulled Brian
aside that's the way like he needs a
hostel I never dated like that okay no
it's great but now how about really and
that isn't a proud like that shouldn't
be surgery yeah yeah whatever
that just that you bleed a lot no I'm
sorry shit Mike it's like I mean you
really got to see it I don't need to I
think we already have to blur one tough
- episode yeah it's so great
like his basically his you ever seen
like a chimps ass yeah it's like bubbles
that's like all big and like a prolapse
yes yes Yoko Athena Phillips that happen
elapsed vagina but that happened to him
on camera
Oh Gina I saw him turns when I thought I
was like I literally oh that I had never
seen anything like this I felt it's
swollen
Yanks sticking out of him like peach
bread ha ha ha ha
and it met it looked like I brought up
look it wasn't like your real asshole
I've been trying to push out a shit for
like the last like three four straight
minutes and I thought that's what it was
that shit was halfway out of my butt I
wasn't trying to show you
you saw it like because you knew that
was what it looked like oh no I thought
there was a piece of shit coming out of
my butt and I was trying to show you
that oh be the most of God I mean when
you thought on yourself were you a
little like oh my god
like yeah yeah okay yeah like a little
scary right it was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah but I was like I can swim should
have been there for a while but why did
that that didn't feel good yeah you're
right rain to wipe it it's fine it's
pretty tough and then it just kind of
goes back in goes back in yeah well see
it all right I mean we've already said
oh no is it what I gotta go do what not
on YouTube I think like liveleak or
something okay I don't know if I
uncensored you clam so it's still like
that re I can show you right now no no
that's okay
bubby yeah that's a terrible thing to
lose I got it I got a bleep some punch
drug ah oh I saw that on the I saw that
yeah I'm tripolis think how that go did
it hurt no a little warm a little little
like heat on it but uh you get to see it
before and after shot like so you can
see why sheena before after it just
seemed like the parts that he didn't
bleach were just darker didn't look like
it was lighter that's so fine that
people are doing that is that real I
mean if you're a porn star I get it but
otherwise in civilian life why would you
need to have your asshole I mean let you
go to an accident and you badly burned
inside your asshole aesthetics guys
won't flag down won't play I'm just like
I'm trying to play it and because I'm
ugly yeah but it just says you know so I
go hit play I'm hitting play right now
the poly video gives it's horrific new
today he can't be over there just won't
play weird well this other one will play
here's a reddit link to it maybe this
will play maybe that this is fun
our pizza dish hmm yeah I'm thinking
again one of those bday things dude
Amazon you don't have to shit to like
get in the shower it's a truck did I
haven't shit the shower I only do it in
hotels now
well yeah now I feel like a diminished
degraded human when I have to shit on a
toilet that doesn't have a good day I
feel like it's I feel like trash so used
to it oh it's going to change your life
it's called the Toto wash let 350 e
Washlet wash let wash lid
I don't know what do you why you saying
like that is it Tom is it wash let or
Washlet Washlet oh I thought it was
French maybe like to even an Ian wash
look heck of a well I don't know if I
could know but it'll really change your
whole shit game yeah I might do that
leave you blood and stuff down there you
should work so now when you do that yeah
then does it stop with a continuous
wiping yeah it's good
cleans it up well the water is what I
need to stop the leaky but well I don't
know why my Platt leaks have you ever
before you got that you ever wipe say
okay I think I'm good then go out and go
I think I'm I think I got to go back to
wipe that's how I've discovered my leaky
blood problem yeah yeah and then like
hours later I'll be like oh my god what
why is there brown there these these
summer days by the way and summer oh
yeah I mean I'm Harry yeah like
sometimes I'll be like itches and I'll
write it down with paper yeah see if
there's something there just like see so
much Brown just like sweat and your your
suit if you walk around New York City
the same way and I just hot where are
you going back then yeah I'm going back
on a run back on Saturday it's kind
place oh you are okay yeah so we going
yeah I'm gonna be there like a couple
weeks just hanging out if you want to
come buddy really
yeah stay indefinitely oh hey can we see
what's up with Danny AK Danny AK yeah
she's a lady she's got a following on
good on YouTube bull yakimaniac
yeah yeah haven't you know I just been
thinking about her yeah well she does
this thing or like she starts basically
all of her are a lot of her videos like
this you go
hey what Hitler yeah she owes us a lot
to Hitler how does that work oh really
yeah
yeah she's just addressing all this up
to Hitler yeah it's a lot of Hitler is
it a back then Hitler I think they did a
lot good distinction okay yeah the
historical Hitler Hitler of today and
she gave him like blog type advice or
she liked admonishing you for some of
the stuff you've done or she's like how
you doing she's like I need some help
oh really yeah it's a cry for Wow yeah
[Music]
basically harassing my day accent he's
harassing me
he's a threatening and actually is Jonas
buzz behind you come here Danny and a
raper something P Q he's been suspended
in my account like a thousand of times
because he's overly jealous
she's real a thousand of times she
basically is obsessed with me he doesn't
know anything about me
right she's in no rush to get to a point
hello girl time in the world
any watching YouTube he loves you too
you know what didn't patagonian I just
wanted to tell what is YouTube all for
the better can we see the update yeah
how's uh thirty seven thousand views
it's not that yeah that's it thank you
we've been Pesci as she studied think to
you guys um well not directly what
should be upset you added you on your
pocket I don't think I yeah real
probably does she say anything if a
Semitic or
like I think she don't remember I don't
remember honestly was it her that had an
anti thousand upon
I just want to let you know the people
in San Antonio the ones just call me my
Danny acts um they basically are chained
up on the candy boat and which I've
already and change them but I know I
thought that we were one know if the
title is all right right right with
honest campy boat yeah shrimp scampi and
I really need your help
I'm saving them further
well Hitler has to do it see ya I'll
just on the boat but untied
yeah we're never gonna do there that she
hasn't already done she's a hero you're
like this is the one I'm talking about
I mean why aren't you I can't ask em
scampi boat and getting turned into like
but Guangzhou yeah especially from this
date we don't hey I owe so is it good
[Music]
all right honest Redskin
hey Leslie Deanie I just want to let you
know there are at least the to my genius
orally to a few my Danny actor on the
shrimp scampi votes yesterday like they
are like getting turned into lasagna so
oh I am move on major help getting an
ice cube out of triple bond and day yes
they really need your help getting
rescued so could you or hilly please
please a send a rescue of but I won't
to her point appreciated days okay babe
they don't hit she she says Hitler she
sang Hitler baby Oh for Christmas and
she sings happy birthday baby
Hitler and other people Hitler did have
access to submarines that's right I mean
it's not out of the realm of like
[Music]
Nicolas no bigger lips what's the video
dog ever say yeah every birthday yeah
nigger lips yeah I don't know if she's
saying that I know it's good and stuff
Oh shrimp scampi boat problem yeah
actually I do anything is to add please
today hobby bye okay oh man that would
have I would have made all those even
movies way lamer yeah the thing I was
looking for is do you remember her one
of her og ones was about shitting in
around yeah I can't fly around and
that's hard to find yeah we could be
looking all day for that I know but she
had a great one about what she was going
to do to this guy when she she's gonna
shit in his mouth and not around it
she's like specified where she was going
really yeah yeah you know Hitler could
only get hard if you show us just no no
you just talk about it like he had a
small dick and then he had a yeah that's
why I always heard where I was rubbing a
latent homosexual and I was growing up
around people who didn't like Hitler why
not were the ones are from I think they
were just not kind of the EU yeah nobody
was trying to unite yeah alright you do
would you rather with Harry would you
rather
yeah like the historical one the big one
okay there's a couple I got I just think
I'll be fun to play with them yeah would
you rather only lasagna for the rest
Eliza yeah or never have to never be
able to eat anything with meat No
one day one day at one meal a day how do
we look pretty I feel like Lauren or no
meat so layer by my brother Jim you
always join sex when your sister thank
you the face bitter distress grandmother
Watson on you masturbating never have
another orgasm I like what I want to I
want to hear my options again it's
either lasagna one meal a day for the
rest of your life every day you have
every day you and Marcy lose a lot
behind that meat and veggies course good
choice okay
but you can anything else kind of like a
little piece lasagna and like a salad is
just was on you for a meal one meal a
day yeah you have two pieces three
pieces but for the rest of your life you
get other meals dinner yeah that could
be lunch okay but you don't have to like
have another thing late you have to eat
it it's a fill-up on it okay you know
it's a it's a be the formula or your
vegetarian oh you're saying no fish as a
vegetarian no fish so no protein you
basically have to be like a V you may
have eggs I see I have to have that
protein I feel I feel weary why I don't
have protein
yeah I'm gonna have to go with the
lasagna once a day if I like lasagna
like I feel like I could do that you
don't feel like you'll be betraying
lasagna by eventually hating it
no okay no what do you say Tommy jeans I
have to do this right now okay arrey
what do you choose hmm I really think it
what I said it do love meat but lasagna
every day I know it's tough because you
know when you make a lasagna you end up
eating it for three or four days other
than I like my day for you're just oh no
yesterday so what was the other option
besides of lasagna your chariot
be a vegetarian no fish you can only
have no bugs
move now well I think I'd have to do
lasagna every single day you know it'll
say whatever you need a tiny square no
no not alone you gotta have your very
own feel serving yeah not allowed but
here's the thing
the variety provided to you and the
other meals I think would we counter it
yeah I feel weak when I don't eat meat
so I like meats what if you had your
lasagna for lunch got other way to go to
a dinner party like we got lasagna today
yeah it would kill someone
yeah wait what would you choose I think
I'd be a vegetarian okay I think I would
get real sick lasagna and I'd start to
go crazy that's true what could you have
different lasagnas like with a bechamel
sauce one day I'd have to be the
standard tomato water feels the way I
pictured it was the same exact recipe
lasagna like when you said you make a
finger lasagna keep eating it imagine
like a 50 mile long one always lasagna
you can have either fresh board heated
up that's the only variety you got
I put shaky cheese on it one day the
next day no shaking I try to vary it I
think I would have to do that just to be
able to have whatever I want for the
second or the third meal I agree I agree
okay Airy ready yes I'm sorry god this
is probably one of our most favorite
would you rather Zahn the show very
popular
would you rather be retarded
hold on I'll stop you there I would love
to I mean let's get another positive or
be a millionaire that I don't know but
like I would love really lack of
responsibility you might feel would be
so worth it you really good fulfilling I
mean you know in the towel hi Oh who's
gonna do that short well for sure not me
right cuz I'm retarded so for sure it's
on me are you guys gonna side who's
doing it but I'm out of this I just go
pee corner what if they make you have a
job like you have to go it's how many
ice or glass racks myself in your little
I thought that don't throw me away
remember
yeah we played it on the show really
yeah you have to go work at the grocery
story not the bag groceries George push
carts yeah stuff like that you get a
retarded guy bagging your groceries the
part of you
feel like part of the solution yeah I
like it I've said this on my face I love
doing this to people I do this to my
mother we were at a grocery store and
they had retarded guy bag in the grocery
hmm and he was at this quarter so they
walk you to the car - so they walk in a
car and they loaded in and so he did he
did all that there's no conversation and
as we're getting in the content where we
go
it's almost different about that guy
right retarded doesn't know like any
other DC things to say and she's I go no
she was don't mean please I go he's fine
and he was like off and clearly approach
her - yeah and she just like just upset
I do that also when I see like somebody
walking like like you know you're go to
fuck with her no yeah like with them
with my parents I'll be like drunk and
that's about zero poly or so and she'll
be like it but they don't like they
don't go they don't get that I'm saying
that I said jokes I do it seriously and
then they'll be like that guy's severely
today starring like he's fucked
oh I love it and I lie and I'm like he's
drunk she could tell yeah I like it on
my friend like oh look at this hot girl
and I turn it's like some 80 year old
fucking asshole because you're expecting
to see somebody super hot you know I
like what Tom does is when he sees a
pregnant woman he'll be like yeah what's
wrong with her stomach
breaking down here I have a stupid I've
posted it on Instagram before yeah and
it's almost like that Colin Quinn thing
we're talking about - blonde Kimberly
was pregnant
no did I post it with Adam West ugh yeah
without I always I have this contract in
my pants I was so a celebrity dies as
soon as possible I will shit on as soon
as they die as soon as I hear about it I
will try to come with a funny tweet
shitting on them yeah not respecting
their death yeah so for Adam West so
they don't really have any problems at
all with Adam West
yeah I was like Adam West fucked my
grandmother it's four apartments at my
father's found I saw that I'll never
forgive him how about no dad Moshe
kasher was like is that real Justin
respond I just like an idiot
no you're in luck we didn't fuck my
softe
so our I tore my family apart but on the
real though I mean I want you to be real
serious your answer would you rather be
retarded or let your grandfather jerk
you off on a ferris wheel but but and
get you get a funnel cake
I think it's choose the ferris wheel you
got a pair of funnel cake yeah right so
it's not a bad day all he does like he
jerked you up on no one finds out
they'll get an awesome fresh funnel cake
yes go ahead does a funnel cake come
before after the jerk-off from the first
yeah after so it's like you're done
right you're crying so those like you
feel better right now like about - yeah
and he goes like just our thing like
don't tell anybody here's a song a final
take yeah feel like the experience of
having this on tape with with Papa would
be uh sort of tainted from the jerk-off
it is sure is but you here's the thing
it's no confidence you have the final
cake before it would be a nice moment my
with my papa or my Saba but then
afterwards would be like nothing to wash
down at that feeling yeah the Saba like
a Jew yeah that's Ben's grandfather got
you bro we have a tough one see ya thank
you know as my Saba going I survived the
Holocaust for this but Philip would you
rather from Christians but okay so but
you're either retarded your whole life
or you do one bad incident on the ferris
wheel but there's funnel cake I approved
you and you got to consider that you
might be get Y in to it and then wanna
have that happen over and over that's
not really but it's not just a one-time
thing
sure I don't I don't talk off to anime
porn for that reason why is that what if
I I don't want to go down that road
right you know and then be like talk
about the cartoons
it's too dark a road other signs yeah
yeah I think I would go with my I mean
is it now or is he still alive
they're both dead yes women they're
still alive he's alive oh yeah yeah not
dig it up his core he's always going
this Ferris well this is an interesting
distinction Ari's making because if it
happened to you in your formative year
your youth it could do long-lasting
damage if it happens at what age are we
talking your child and this happens are
you an adolescent or are you 40
something year old also if you're an
adolescent you're just 17
you're gonna come quick sure but now I
mean you're going to be jerking me off
for a while like I'd ever go to the guy
running like run that back run that back
we got another round on a ferris wheel
right so well listening to saying oh you
fucking hands
I hope there's air Lube is there Lube or
is it just that rough Nana grandpa and
rock yeah yeah ruff ruff all right now I
think you know what I'm going to do with
this one cuz I hadn't considered the age
I don't want to scar you emotionally too
much so I'm not going to attend to a
child from now on I'm gonna go that's
great 40 something you're always Mary
you're an adult and your grandfather is
like a couple years before he dies right
we hold his hand all decrepit but also I
get to have had 40 years of non retarded
life and yes right didn't go back and
become always target right so you'll be
born retarded and whatever semester
comes out like a mysimon retarded and
interview talking about it so why did
you choose do a double special unlike TV
I'm interesting they're like wrong with
you right now
I play would you rather I know this
married couple
the sort of fake and phony so now yeah I
call it my grab my grip on something new
it's not because if you just live the
rest of his life return it that'll be
really crazy oh wait is it not live us
really well that's what I thought I
assumed that you'd be born we'd go back
in time and you're born retarded but we
got to make choices right now so you can
convert that's all right now
I think it might be funnier if from now
on I think it's better though it's
better to listen let's go from that from
now on you're retarded from now on
you'll be hard too because I've gotten
laid and then the amount of game I would
not have and your careers then when I
let you become the retarded comedian now
my intellect wouldn't be there to write
the bits but here's the other thing we
can hire dart getting do you start
getting
sympathy tale the officer yeah you don't
look the same way people remember you
before you walk into a bar and then
they're like hey I saw your Netflix
incoming Central okay you would get a
bunch of women who would like we're
already booked to me like whatever like
but not enough yellow is my favorite
yeah and then they like oh wow I kind of
thing for a Tartar people yeah
also he was a funny comic once this
one's okay you give a whole new life
your sex game with people take a big
dive you would never think about
pleasing somebody else know what you got
also think I have retard strength yeah
so and a retard libido don't forget they
are very sexually and they took off
constantly because they don't know like
you're not supposed to do this like why
would you not do good you have to try it
what we got right we got hate mail about
that really says she said that and some
someone wrote in like I work with in
special ed she's like they don't all
jerk awful day you fuck me that's cuz
you've done a good job they're so mad
everybody says we're going to get some
mail on this okay think yeah but it's so
we're the hate mails never like oh just
you know some of them dudes that but
generally that's like 510 percent you're
off a little bit yeah fuck you I thought
yeah is really they go right thanks for
not teaching let me ask you this though
yeah you know you're gonna have a
decision because yeah yeah yeah okay but
then walk us through the logic I'm not
here yet
tell us your decision and tell us why
you chose that yeah I think I would go
with my grandfather jerk me off
wow I just don't want to be retarded man
I just don't my retarded and I thought
some gross people before yeah this would
be way more damaging but I wasn't that
close with Papa or cassava how long do
you think it would take you to finish it
would take a while
what I'm I try to draw off before the
two guys in the oil Comedy Store the
condo I try to work it up like real hard
in the other room yeah and then come out
and like jizz in front of them oh my god
and yeah when I came out realize how
ridiculous it was it I was about to come
and then it was I know you got a five
more minutes now and I need to go back
for an hour made there curiously you too
nervous was it the pressure of a
performance it was just like ridiculous
and funny teeth were they laughing with
a one was laughing one was in horror
yeah I think I choose the lab
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna go grandfather
jerking me off Wow yeah it would be
rough it would take a while it would
definitely damage me oh man what does
the thing is that it's going to go back
the rest of your life I have a
definitely a new I have a my parents
have trouble looking at them yeah yeah
especially telling it like you have to
tell one day you know what you know what
your dad did yeah
the name should really be called would
you least rather yeah of course not like
what about this one it leads us into one
of the classic would you rather and I
know you're not obviously Christian but
like the biggest celebratory day in your
house would probably be like growing up
would be passing like weight for
celebration oh oh you mean like yet
person was more like a family thing yeah
Hannukah Hannukah your family there
though
but everyone see you know Passover
Passover Rosh Hashanah okay that's a
rehearsal for sure okay Passover yeah so
it's Passover everybody gets together oh
my god I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I am
hodgepodge gosh I am Barris fucking nah
it's a good at that you leave a
different but oh my god you guys are so
disgusting so if you guys have your you
know you said yeah you sacrifice your
baby you do you're saying oh the time
Jewish babies does right okay he's a
grown man kill a dog you guys do you
change black your prayer you know
there's one drop of Jewish non Jewish
baby blood in the matzo recipe if that's
your burger with one drop it don't talk
it's not a whole baby we for sure we
killed the babies and put them out but
like only one drop let's say you're way
off base okay I don't know all the
things but you do your coin flip
everyone sits there and then at the end
right is there like a big toast and
everything - yes I'm bored Rosses along
okay so there's all this wine then you
say to your family you go guys I got to
show you something and you everybody
goes from the dining room allows this to
the living I don't know about okay I
already picture that so everybody is
like how cool and they're like what is
it did you shoot a new show what are you
going to show us and you go just sit
here and watch this
and you put it a DVD so and they're all
like waiting in their mom eating a
Grammy and would it by the way is been
faster do you say Happy Passover like
what do you guys play so happy what
there's a happy Pesach place Oscar okay
that's a okay orchid yontiff good
yontiff yeah okay so after all holidays
so they're all sitting in front of the
TV you press play your on screen and ten
homeless guys are standing around you
and they hold all over it's all over
somehow it goes yeah this is one of the
options of course it's a video of both
no no no no it's one or the other oh my
god sorry you're right I continue right
go ahead divorced over know about that
we go okay could be lazy here okay okay
okay okay yeah yeah but their homeland
mixture is homeless yes and they all
masturbate to incompletion yeah I'm on
it
and he on you know and they're squirting
or no no no one that's Owen oh yeah
because it could be like Stuart and
they're like yeah they're all really
loud about it it's really uncomfortable
oh my way Army's watching yes wait yes
now when I use the lasso everybody ready
yeah although the last one ends you turn
the camera and you say happy place off
yeah happy place off like that and then
it cuts to black you turn back now what
do you guys think it's either that or
when you put the DVD in and you press
play it's just you alone looking the
camera and you masturbate to completion
and you say happy face off yeah so it's
the shame that it's either you doing the
thing or having the thing done to you
that's shameful I mean I there's so many
different people in the family yeah
well my mom and dad even was
disappointed with me versus like I could
explain to the nephews if I was just
masturbating my sister's could be like
okay you're going to live this
eventually yet what all he was doing was
called masturbation you'll do it when
you get a little older do we have to
take that can we take the children out
of the room I think the children don't
need to be privy I'm going to take one I
no one needs to be privy well let's
let's
change it to just adults I don't think
it's fair to put kids and that's in
there so I'm picturing me when I was
growing up they when I'm like 22 no one
has it as being right those kids correct
I've what's grown-up correct it's just
adults only is what we've judged it to
Tom children shouldn't watch the video
because your mom is your dad it's your
grandma grandpa everywhere their
brother-sister they well there's no
children okay yeah so that's all the
dollars okay can I say a problem with
this yeah I had can't use a DVD player
on Ianto so it would be okay because I'm
like I got to put this a DVD Alec what
are you talking about no I have the
caveat here it is it's a live
performance guys kind of my friends
they're all going to do this with me
versus all right guys and actually the
way I come to the backyard
yeah we were actually originally the way
I like this one is to send out a
company-wide email guys come to my desk
at 12:30 and everyone shows up your boss
I'm in your life and then you that's a
good way to masturbate that's a good way
to quit your job but what would you guys
do with grandfather or retarded I'd
rather go retarded no I'd rather
grandfather 100% yeah now we're I've
lived a great life all but my son shit
grandfather I have to raise my kid but I
feel like it would like now that I think
about it talking about with you it would
take so long so I'll go somewhere like
it's focused so intently on it you know
just you have to block out like so hard
it's a really mistake about sexual stuff
yeah hard if you like at all pop up or
if you get that smell bengay yeah and
every time he's like Oh clean throwings
like you know any wouldn't be good at it
don't like Jesus I could lick his hand
the way doesn't
[Music]
yeah and I hope you're like having
trouble I go do your balls yes yes I do
I need help
you're my laughs like old times yeah you
want me to do your balls yeah Craig -
your balls man balls grabbed by my area
so what's it going to be and everyone
okay yeah
so jerk off in front of my family or
have ten girls kind of boot cocky you I
mean originally it was ten homeless men
but I feel like we adapt it for male but
they're really a shame men and women
homeless and they're being bored so if
I'm Russ do it homeboy jay ellyiot
suppose that's what it sounds like
[Music]
like on the backyard I mean they just
get a watch I feel like I got not just
what now everyone just watching her just
like shocked yes service yeah so you're
really thinking about the conversation
afterwards caucus three you're thinking
you okay you think about afterwards how
to deal with you also think about if no
one was there which I read it's like I
don't want to have homeless people
jizzing on me
like it's not just about the reaction
it's also like this is happening all
right my interesting point and just a
quick but can't you masturbate in front
of your family that's another thing
looking into your mother's eyes looking
at your sister right right right yeah I
mean like forget that the homeless
people jizan on you and squirting on you
that could be a would you rather if the
family's not even involved because it's
not even a good thing
yeah but the family adds a nice little
job for sure I'm saying it the facet but
masturbation without my family is no big
deal without your family your family
that's a whole other level that's why
it's such an important would you rather
this is a seminal one if you know hmm I
think I think I know but am I thinking
is nothing thank you
I could sort of know it off to them it
was like rock I was fast to do this I
wasn't the one doing it that's right
that was a lot masturbating that's right
though it's a more normal thing like
obviously you know it's electrolyte but
I do this when you're not around right
and now the home Anthony it's a shoulder
it's a shame displacement it's either
the shaming is done to you or you're
responsible for your shame so that's I
think my psychologically very hawkish
as I'm talking to him I just wish yeah I
was gonna go get get judged on right but
I think maybe now masturbating but then
again to conversation afterwards I'd be
like no you were doing that are you
asked about why did you do it's past we
asked you to stop we're saying hey
please stop the other way it's like we
asked the homeless people to please stop
yeah and they did it alright get away
from them but I'm on the ground I may
have and they they take the
responsibility right what's happening
made him do this yeah oh they forced me
alright
I'm a I lost the border
this is a really underline one the goals
whenever you do a would you rather it
does not have people go oh yeah hey or
right yeah CF it's the dilemma yeah yeah
I think getting masturbated on do you
prefer that one I don't prefer I don't
like using that word so it's your
preference it's what you find enjoyable
I think that but there would be that
conversation of like I masturbated was
you that in front of us but this like -
what are you into look that's all that's
an ending whatever in commerce of our
son so that's interesting the shame of
what are your sexual preferences are you
into this is what our ease into versus
we don't know what our ease into but
he's masturbating in front of us I'm not
I masturbated in their house while they
were there when I was in Orthodox -
right Alice times were you supposed to
not do that oh for sure not there's no
religion in the world that I know of no
even that that does that allows it will
you ever bring stuff like that up in
that era would you be like I want to
masturbate or they talk to you that
stuff like that no no no even sexy ahead
was how hardcore are your folks Orthodox
Jewish they are yeah they have gotten to
the point whether if we're out my dad's
like can I get a burger you can get a
burger oh really I would that like took
a lot how are they with your you know
success like I like my success they
don't like the way I've achieved it like
when I took my dick out on HBO my mother
party I told people to watch you're
gonna be on TV
Larry why my mommy shouldn't watch it's
tough it's exactly not free will they
watch the special oh yeah they will yeah
I got Comedy Central before they got
cable just later watch me really yeah
they're proud of me as my aunt once I
was doing some jokes I like herpes at
the BC improv yeah they were there and
they left right afterwards when I was
like what did they how did they feel
about that she goes I think they just
assumed you were joking about like to
set up endless payoff oh that it's all
made up yeah yeah that's good you're
like I'm joking about having it though
not having it fucking excuse me making
love to a woman so I could make love to
a woman who had herpes on there like
others just won't it's amazing how many
people like will there like until you
just made that whole thing up right no I
just chose the funniest way to say
amazing one to me is when people think
you made up like a super detailed story
like a story yeah like people can
they're like so you may like I had a
story about meeting Mike Tyson and
they're like you write all that up you
make that up really creative if you
could do that I mean you kind of want to
be like yeah I think I'm creative but
like you think I mean I've made up all
the beats of like our Congress like that
why would I like that yeah
but I guess if you don't do it then you
just they don't know don't let them see
behind the curtain guys come on I know
but I just weird it like you just know I
was like what is like Louis got a plan
like me I just do oh look at me yeah
now does your mom do the thing where she
when she gets her period she goes to the
water the jacuzzi lakpha
yeah I like that a lot my mom hasn't
gotten a period since before Obama for
sure
Oh probably back and I like that idea
you have to make it what is it 40 almost
of natural water it's a measurement of
natural water you need okay after you
have your period you need seven clean
days so no spotting no nothing count one
two like popcorn when it pops and you're
like three seconds ago one to pop okay
start again one two three pop want you
know what so you get seven clean days no
spotting everything again spot starts
over when you get seven clean days in
you go to the mikvah ritual bath you can
also use a lake or ocean because it's
got plenty of water in there natural
water but not like a pool it's got to be
like a natural heavy rain water coming
in I always think about whenever I hear
these things like that it's crazy right
no just the amount of effort didn't
effort I guess we're all well let me
tell you this in terms of like what you
said like practicality yeah so period
looks like three five days depends
falling yeah dead seven clean days now
your date 12 yeah so you're going to
ovulate soon the next day go to mikvah
13 and now you're you haven't fucked
your husband in 1314 and you're at your
most fertile
yeah it's great it's actually a way of
making carry a baby boy juice and it's
not so can you like yeah I think also
like just relationship was you guys go
to a road so when you're apart make sure
that when you're exactly like oh I can't
wait to see you again is true versus
you've seen a lot of doubles miksa you
should hunt I do I like what does you
say okay I got some good shit yeah what
are you privately
do you do anything like symbolically
anymore like to you anything sighs
masturbate in front of your family the
food sack
I still get off on that because I grew
up with it but it's on home I'll sing
their songs with them oh you know it
just sounds really at this point but do
they is everybody hears nothing how are
they as far as they have they accepted
your they are generative but my dad
wants to also sheet onto the shoulder
mark you know come with friends we know
I feel bad like I went home so you say
the grace after meals there's this if
you have three or more men above
thirteen there's an extra player say and
one person says that everyone like joins
in so you say like it's in Hebrew but
you say like bless it up for giving us
food and I was like yeah for real though
like Thanksgiving here is like - totally
yeah it's a back and forth a little bit
yeah my dad's like you want to leave
this one like members
he's like no you read another book and I
was like my moms like do it I'm like ah
no but then as soon as I didn't know
like what the fuck is wrong with me
yeah just not you know I'm not I'm not
converting I've done it if I was at a
Buddhist thing and they said can you be
this thing I would have done it yeah so
it's like that's because it's family
into traditions what I mean like I don't
bad about it yeah okay can we get back
to the fucking question at hand
yeah he hasn't chosen sorry so hard I've
never had somebody somebody really
mulled all there is already the before
and it's a during that's a friend after
the during the complaining to them it's
like course domestic what you doing re
why now it's masturbation so taboo yes
it is for your house it's not a normal
thing it's not a natural occurrence
meaning that's the double thing of you
having Orthodox parents real is that you
know that's off the table discussion why
yeah I like white trash parents like why
are you doing that outside you know
right hey what's your choice what is it
pressure baby I I think it's the
homeless people yeah yeah I do think
that yes no I think I chose the other
one I chose doing it myself
he's got good parents I could tell them
afterwards the whole G like I wasn't
into that right right right
right now I understood I mean I I got it
I I just I thought I rejected all the
other come
no I displaced the shame I prefer to put
the shame on the other people one of the
I'm not lasting already one not me it's
them the og would you rather yeah well
it's great when you come across a good
one you're like I gotta numbers for next
time oh this one is like from yeah he's
like a six or seven year old one now I
have one for you for me yeah you could
do this to area with it
okay Tommy would you rather would you
rather have your mouth smell like beef
why do our dog our blind dog gives us
smells like my smelly food is my I wish
the other one I look for you oh you
don't want to like it now it's like a
halibut fucking funny it's horrible yeah
okay so would you have either your mouth
smells like beef or my mouth smells like
beef yours why white really yeah but
then you have to live with me and I'll
have a garbage mouth yeah I know I just
have you just kiss other parts you know
yeah but that we remember owner in terms
of like her feelings the perfect woman
you loved like it'll be easier for you
right easier for me to have your mouth
don't have to smell his horrible mouth
he's going to have a bad smelling mouth
anyways cuz dad's dad mouth you're going
to have dad mouth in like when you're 50
right don't dad's mouth smell like shit
anyway like older guys now like a weird
face ya know like the deodorant I put it
on and they and they look like like
older guy mouths would look like they're
just decomposing look at it I feel like
you look like a fucking it's like a
corpse already yeah see I feel like it'd
be I be like can I get it anyway I think
we would get to the point I'd be like
you know how your mouth is so you would
be like hey can I get a kiss I'd be like
this how your cheek you know you kiss
you over there the thief's mouth smells
horrendous it does you wouldn't be able
to sleep next to me like I couldn't
sleep with my head next to your head on
the pillow
oh no the other bedrooms yeah I would
just no I just be like face the other
what you know you know yeah you know you
face your wall yeah I would have you
smell like thieves man I would have the
math your wife is ebooks or thing yeah
yeah the other person has that you can
get around your fucking day yeah I can
have my life I want your life I would be
talking to pee
and you could I mean if they had like my
dog if I had my dog brother people good
hoof Jesus man what you want to mint and
Roma strong enough you wouldn't be able
to do anything I don't like beef mint
yeah I have a serious one for you guys
okay I'm serious which round
would you rather never do stand-up ever
again
we're to put up Oh God God because I
mean I plotted people about comedians
this is who we are at the core so like
split up but just did divorce but we can
still see each other like split up
meaning you're done on paper you're nice
to each other yeah baby fuck once a year
yeah yesterday Oh how's it going how's
things going with you when you drop them
off now you the kids fine she's both the
parents you guys are both amicable I
mean oh it sucked but I'd have to I want
our family together I don't want my kid
to grow up the way I did terrible fine
what about that support no it's not at
what it's not good yeah split up but
babe what well here's the thing you make
you make a good living doing Santa you
would really have to find another I mean
the podcast is great too
but that would really ruin your
livelihood and our livelihood and I like
jewelry you know what I'm saying we are
split up now I get massages and stuff so
white diamonds of course I got it for
yesterday
really my birthday present anything I
don't know your birthday was your summer
February it's coming no one cares about
February what do you want to go in this
fucker anyway what true oh yeah oh yeah
yeah I heard ectopy guy talking about
your trip Lopez I wasn't hiring though
yeah thanks man unless you say I'm thank
you is mine I bought it thank you furs
no it's ma'am beautiful casinos there's
taste in jewelry is amazing
what stuff fuck man so I talked to Bart
yeah Crisler yeah and the the the the
Rio beast yeah yeah
Bart Chrysler yeah so what is your
opinion on his weight gains is
man I don't know I was trying to spin
this even when he took a shirt off for
that thing and weight himself I'd not
obese he still looked obese as fuck you
mean at the actual way yeah January 3rd
I guess that's when I was little we look
you saw him you saw him with me a few
days ago yeah what do you think he
looked like you looked well he doesn't
look like a fucking workout guy right
but he said he definitely cut wait for
the weigh-in right well we both caught
water horse but like there's you put the
water back on yeah and exactly it says
his face doesn't look much different
than he did way before yeah he's just so
gross and like we were talking weeks on
the back yeah pushed out where it's a
hard if he lost weight you should have
that foot that fold over yeah saying a
little bit a little bit right do you
feel like because he was saying I mean
I'd like to get him back on a scale
maybe I will
throwing uh is he going to skank fest I
don't know where he's going he's he's on
the road a lot yeah
if you if you were to describe he said
that he was really upset what that
people were saying he gained the weight
back
yeah well he no but he's upset about is
that he came to lay back right I don't
know maybe and I was like well you know
he goes I have no here's what he said
yeah it's a lot and I go dude he goes
heard you said hey did tell me he was
like fucking Tom who's throwing up again
to give the bleep hook yeah and people
have been tweeting him really yeah like
why did you get fat again looks good I'm
on a scale ago yeah but I don't know you
saw him and at least for our audience
for me to tell difference to 220 and 240
yeah you know he's a nice guy
you understand that but he's a tall guy
he's over six feet tall well over six
feet tall well over six one you know
well into the six six feet so I think
he's just under six one you're just
under six feet but he's well over six
feet Mitch a liar I can't believe I
can't believe after asking for the
fucking measurement when you were well
over an inch shorter than you said you
were there was no I said I was six feet
who said you were six one
I didn't say six one you still always
said it take one he said he was six one
which turned out to be also not true yes
so then they had to do new BM eyes yes
but you guys both narrated anyway but
that being said he is fat again
sorry yes she is obese again yeah how do
we know Bert we don't know we don't know
just look at him
I mean he's not doing anything that he's
supposed to be doing to lose the weight
but he managed it before I don't know
how he did it before it's legal only
cram for test and still Magica A's yeah
that this isn't the way it's gonna work
but it does his vision is it the Mickey
Mantle gene mukesh to him you know I
thought was really funny was that that
was the phrasing of it where you go what
was it it was good just good out of
abuse let's just get out of here that's
all you ever do just don't be oh be be
overweight be overweight yeah talking
medically obese and by the way he lacks
the Lance of fun of faith and either of
us was also here to do the only one you
can do it I don't know you both do it no
way yeah it's like if you really did
have a good work out of it yeah for sure
but I didn't think I don't want a mic
can I ask you one thing it's so dumb and
it's like such a minor dumb question but
I've been thinking about it there was a
time during their weigh-ins where Joe
called you and you were abroad and he
kept calling you and calling you and
like you know I was I was a with
comedians in New York we're out eating
trans career I would I'd left the next
day why did you not just answer the
phone like you kept answer and then
you'd hang up oh it's because of this
because I have the new feature my phone
is just moved by little don't answer in
my pocket
oh this whole time I'm like why would I
do that I don't know why you would do
that to somebody was my last was the
first way and I waited so I guess midway
through the second part that's when I
left so weird yeah that's all it wasn't
when I finally thought oh what I was
kind of drunk with the guys okay I know
like what a jerk why you stay on the
phone yeah well it was it was like let
me show you the way in here's the
numbers like wait wait I need to know
what the BMI is like what do they have
to be way more downloading got word that
we were basically whatever at or near
that were you like fuck like did you go
a little bit also fun but okay I'm all
about competition yeah I'm like I want
the exact measurement yeah it was like
the
I did it I'm like man could slow down
slow down
yeah we do have the we have waitress you
do not it by by the way after your new
weight your new height yeah five
something I'm bleep unbelievable okay
yeah you were point 1/5 of an inch above
obese if you were point one five point
one five if you were if you were five
eleven point seven instead of five
eleven point a five you would be obese
yeah so for the next day it's like hey
man if he gains a pound back yeah I win
the bet so I'll say like let me see the
fucking competition oh my god I've never
shirked on a goddamn single best
nightlife so what are we gonna do though
what should we do let's do something
August aw man I'm free I have a pretty
busy fall that's miles let me ask you a
question what what about in November me
and and Burt will be in New Orleans
going that Joker's cruise will be
launching from there yeah so maybe
something is November football season I
say it in really fun um nobody really
you know what would be really fun we
have to put it off obviously a little
bit yeah would be in probably end of
January
yeah I don't even know where it is like
a look it up yeah the national
championship game that'd be fun to go to
basketball no wait whatever college
football college football yeah that'd be
good your huge sells football fan yeah
okay it's always on a Monday end of all
right yes that's great yeah okay let's
do it
we could do that put your Tim fi see you
they have no chance next year they do no
I mean that there would be a sort
they're going to be a preseason top top
ten yeah so there's a chance yeah
there's a chance and by the way because
they also open the season against
Alabama
that'd be the show they'll get theirs
they'll get a pretty good jump up if
they went out and they stopped it off
they win that yeah they'll be like my
conversation yeah yeah yeah that'd be
good
i I didn't I like the idea of going to
Barcelona
I'll be on Steve that was rooted in
truth yeah I also knew how I have
retarded it kind of like but then when
it was like actually like when we were
like hey let's do it I was like that'll
be super fun super fun yeah well made
like a big like an air baby together I
thought that'd be fun in Barcelona or
Bali because they were play
and the games ended up being like crazy
good game oh really
one of the UH one of them was I think
one of them well that there was a big
shocker because I guess they had they
had multiple remarked you know yeah can
to paint one estanque yeah so there was
one big upset or I think Paris beat
Barcelona but no one was expecting on
the first one and I think there's a game
after that we're Barcelona when you play
for Barcelona yes yeah yeah yeah
wow yeah that would've been fun it would
have been fun man but anyways when I by
the way I had my plan set up cuz you
like a Wi-Fi first class I'm like you
know what is your flight that's fine and
I was already had a set like you're
flying first class at Burt and I are in
the back yeah by the way I know they
would have harassed me who would have
Bert oh yeah he would have been like
what'd he do it was good for exactly
what I have no doubt to be told you
can't be up here and he was been so
upset to be in coach so upset I'm select
the middle suit I was going to get him
oh god the worst yeah we have to do
we'll have to do like a so temperature K
would be pretty me look at everything
yeah me see what yeah absolutely
okay is that soccer yeah now definitely
split up that would be a cool one for
sure and then I can finally stop getting
comments on all my fucking everything I
posed that's gonna call me a well sure
yeah an upcoming game it will be played
in Atlanta Atlanta when you marry a hey
can we go to the vortex and get that
peanut butter banana burger absolutely
and it's a new stadium like a new state
of the art over a billion dollar stadium
yeah fuck you yeah that could be fun
okay what is it January 31st January 8th
dinner ace yes is that cold
I think way early no no no that's right
they do the New Year's Eve stuff I don't
know it doesn't snow there in Atlanta it
can vary it gets cold but not that cold
not that cool oh yeah I'd like to what
we're good yeah yeah okay you guys you
want to go do that yeah that could be a
thing yeah let's do it
I'll not schedule everything ahead of
time now all right so it'll probably go
for like the week the weekend you gotta
go for a couple days yeah yeah just land
goes yeah championship game but yeah
we'll go for earless even goes Sunday
and then stay Monday Tuesday Wednesday
something yeah
two bandits banger because we do like
the fishing or some I would have we can
figure out so much okay
hell yeah that'll be great okay nice
right I hope I kill myself before that's
what I'm actually pay it off so cheap
oh so I might have to get two seats for
Burke if he keeps going at this rate
that's totally true no enormous yes he
though I wonder if it's just that you
know we always see him shirtless we
never see him that was my theory by the
way but windows true when he told me he
goes when he said like everyone saying I
go straight back I go dude
every place you go you don't have a
shirt on most people not even like
forget obese like the average person
shirtless is it isn't like wow you look
great
you know what can I tell you but maybe a
retort to that yeah I'll take my shirt
off constantly yeah Manhattan anywhere I
see items
shirts off for sure sun's out guns out
you know yeah and uh when I have my
shirt off especially after I got that
beep like oh man you so tan jewel is
wait right and with him there saying did
you gain weight
it's just because the baseline product
isn't good right right
alright so like like no same buddies
before like you okay now I will say that
I will say this yeah I walk around all
the time shirtless yeah it's not going
to be compliments men no it's not going
to shine but it ya know but like most
people have the sense
- him wonder how the night waves I want
I want to go to scale what would your
guess be if you had a guess right now I
don't know - 90 I don't think it's the
way I even I know that's really hot man
she's like is that got to be off by like
10 pounds I don't know man it's gotta be
like - 78 to 80 I think that is that
real so really every day the way back
he's not above 240 yeah but but he
waited it I think - 20 yeah no - 22 you
had to - 19 the well the final day I was
- 16 and 0 to 20 I think yeah yeah I
would just love that she I didn't we did
the BMI and Rover have to go fuck the
booth thing the boo thing that Evan
grants for Carol yeah that's really hard
if you lose weight and drink whenever I
see a woman especially the comedy scene
and suddenly it's like when I would seen
them take some
it's like hey you look great like what
are you doing it's 90% of time stop stop
drinking
absolutely that's the one thing you
can't you can't do both man you can't
lose weight Anna
I was I was gaining weight when I was
traveling for the first like about month
uh-huh and I was like my getting pudgy
rs.10 making sense I mean like no
processed foods
I'm activist fuck yeah and my friends
like Chang wait drinking beers year two
and year is really awesome it is like 20
ounces for like a dollar and he is a
psycho though where he will go
you know serialism okay if you if you go
on his like Instagram it's like every
night he's like I gotta borrow you 40
people have see buddy then up and the
next day he goes and he runs he does
yeah so he negates the damage he does
that self regulating thing where he's
like I'm brooding tonight but you're in
California right okay I'll do the five
miles yeah you can't exercise your liver
though yeah yeah no I asked him two
years from now
oh god he's so great yeah it's a good
car got it leasing them we shot a living
memorial for him like a living funeral
eggs we can really feel his friends come
out yeah we should have you to do it
before his heart attack what vulnerable
but like let's how to living more in
Atlanta but booking for a show I'm gonna
do this show and then when he shows up
just have like the big photo I mean I
was underneath oh yeah that would be
great and had people just have fun were
music playing yeah the intervention is
that it yeah you like you know this a
real bummer to be so upset yeah for a
little outf are gonna miss you yeah it's
too real lows too close yeah the reality
did you ever have like a horrible office
corporate job yeah yeah templates up to
the Health Network you guys are really
like cool law firm stuff getting to know
each other
[Music]
no look at the people fairly topic um
and so everybody's doing this Wow all
better overworked
well guy wrote in the he had he had
amenities he wrote in that he was like
my name is Kevin yeah and I killed a man
and he really did things stuck because
he was in Afghanistan yeah but his like
the first thing that came to mind was I
killed a man he said it looks big for
him at what and but like everyone
stopped me like um me bro yeah we got
through the ice yeah somebody hey sent a
yeah booyah I knew one of these and now
we're Shibuya fucking dumb why people
shit I hope you have a flip and I said
[Applause]
oh my god I mean and then it's like then
he like says are we
jeez you're going to be a cashier window
yeah wow thanks thanks for the fucking
endorsement an old dad outfit by the way
we bought my jeans tucked in yeah
t-shirt and the Denver shoes those
Denver rugged sneaks well see people
wearing really good look awesome yeah
man was my dog what is NEX I a thousand
of of something oh yeah yeah all right
a black man this guy they've all my dad
jeans on look at this dork here with his
wife sneakers dad Jean do you think the
one next to that guy up to his right
see that's it yeah no yeah that one no
no the girl the lady
yeah do you think uh I think she's like
the office like slut yeah she's a hot
girl people of hook up with our drama oh
yeah
there's always look at hockey
oh my god one first I'd kill myself was
so through I think oh we and then use
here he did manage to make a verse that
that held the it did good Kate and open
everything yet
yeah sure something really different you
know it's a bummer I was it's like
another marketing song from a convention
for for convention
showing you things you like gotta get
engagement photos from my life my cat my
kids some bacon my son and tweet it to
you tell me grow my clouds a great boys
hummus better is good so connect with me
[Music]
Wow I get my cat my kids someday social
that guy does not have a though he wrote
it he wrote that song oh really yeah
Milli Vanilli oh sure yeah now the
bummer I was going to say about that
Walmart one yeah it's like look you take
a job at Walmart at least I would for
the chill factor like you know not a lot
of heavy responsibility you clock in you
clock out you don't have no one fucking
watching you and then to have to suffer
through that corporate nonsense it takes
the whole fun out of working there in
the first place I would love at that
point I would love to see the end of
that video when he's like whatever class
and somebody goes hey man I quit put
your hand back down and walk out yeah
the guy that goes like almost seen these
fucking songs yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
enough to work here place that up yeah
with that song over his like dude I
won't do this Ronnie I'm your manager
you don't do any 100k Zombo you know
like a really enthusiastic thing I'm
gonna be a cashier one day all right he
was it better in terms of like letting
you know because it should have been it
was a real song is we like two more
verses yes so he let me know with the
hand off that this song is over he did a
way better job in The Groundlings ooh
yeah it's like ending something true he
knew there was there was a time limit
yeah yeah
[Music]
why did I go together
that was really good I drew them later
thank you very that is a two of them
later why would he not know he does not
sound good on that yeah social not very
I'm trying to I had a I used to work at
a company called world link that sold
airtime for infomercials it was really
bad 95 and I remember they used to just
have us come in and on quarterly
meetings and then they would go over the
earnings and then we'd have to clap at
the earnings and you'd like it but I'm
making $5 an hour late I'm clapping for
this fuckin CEO sixty-eight million in
products like awesome man hahahahaha the
guy's great but they didn't have these
demeaning shibuya is in session shibuya
we had icebreaker that was like in like
dorm jobs well right although I hate
situations where they go we're going to
go around the room and say your name and
like something I did in post-production
like where you get the whole together
and I go around you had Tom post
coordinator hi and I like and what was
your favorite thing to it's really just
unduly punishes the introverts I had in
yeah I took an acting class in college
and we had to go around doing the same
thing you split up into twos and then do
something interesting about yourself
where you from and then you report on
the other person so I was like to the
person the woman doing me I was like I
want so I'm just gonna make something up
like I don't sure whatever so I said
that I wanted the price is right and I
bid $1 and then there was still one got
to go and he bid $2 and he ended up
winning and there were two football
players in the class yeah it was an easy
a and so the lady said interviewed me
was like okay Ari's once on The Price is
Right he bid $1 and then the guy after
the $2 and one and the full players like
man bullshit because me a bad
motherfucker you know I was trying to do
you know what I was trying to do
oh my god well I mean it's fake but the
rules would you shouldn't be doing $1.00
with the still people that they go yeah
Wow we still worked up for me black eye
yeah yeah sound like yeah figure someone
bit but Danny ecwid sing too oh yeah
Hitler pain black eye in my acting class
you got something lips so humor caper uh
the guy that did your mom's house song I
don't we got a lot of songs but he did
it like like an actual real song about
he did another one but he shot like a
video oh my god let's see it so this is
it's alright going back to our house and
we shot up the main mommy are you like
when Tom Cruise calm now ranch calm your
mom's house podcast calm suck your mom's
house amazon banner eat up your mom's
house go back to your mom's house
go back to your mom's house I'm going
through your mom how that was great yeah
go all the of the lingo Oh max name what
you Pro now I'm just asked it's not
sexual I'm just glass and I'm trying to
got damage they call me duct tape oh my
non-binary fuck lay on the crack like I
don't wanna sing that can't barking I
use the bathroom that your mom's had to
hold my nose about I had to take a shit
hold up I got something to say hey I
really was just like the guest hey June
huh show me how to run it shit like my
Bristol stool chart on seven diamonds on
the strip itself you push you over you
denim I met your mama dip's ago wouldn't
a handicaps all this was champion if I
had becoming my boss I'm going to Wow
now back to your mom's house go back to
you mind going back to your mom's house
I'm going into it or no I like to have
in common
laughing I'm I like that hilarious go
back to your mom's house Jeanne rocking
the bottle of peach your mama anyone
believe I'll call you from the potty
who's been talking shit we'll listen to
some mommy music cool stuff take a five
string water natural Michael oh yeah no
one tell me know what I mean my dad's on
the stuff in the winter machine mr.
blocker girls had the better love life I
got a bad bike she never on the come
strike we fucked at the modern-day
coffee and a couple triple D's clucks no
no my promo Danny I said I got a
question want to ask y'all would you
rather be retarded get jerked by your
grandpa there you go Wow
go back to you Milo going back this is
an amazing great I'm going to your mom
mom going back to your mom's house go
back to your mom's whistles I love that
slow the winds off caper that was amazed
that would really oh yeah yeah yeah
breeds ahead of time he'd like to go to
Amazon link and fun yeah what ideally he
wrote us a note taking a shit I wrote a
little song made a video hope you liked
it had a blast recording filming writing
editing it I hope it makes it on the
show I left the third verse open for the
mommy rappers to rap on I love you have
any questions
keep those jeans high and tight thanks
for last word is fat again that's the
new mantra burn fat again maybe the next
name thank you so much paper that would
really make his last name that again
yeah burst out again per fat against
love hey Ari I have a question for you
you know how when you go to fart but you
shit and it's called a shart
but what about when you go to take a
shit and you only fart what's that
called not fit fit that's a good one we
haven't read that one
so what a thump apart dump yeah no son
how does that happen to you guys a lot
attendant do want to have there's new
submissions oh in here there is
something no I like in poster or
Sharklets by the way somebody this is a
new one are you ready for this
someone said if you feel this shit but
only fart you had yourself a fit yeah
someone says it sorry someone says it's
de Jean poo
we call it a McConaughey do so failure
to launch oh and this one's great jag
wrote try areia favorite really I think
it's try areia a few weeks of submission
that is try real yeah I like impostor
charlatans and try areia and posters
really funny god yeah water ball huh
water bowl for no you got to get
yourself a dog
they won't like oh my god do I go the
road oh you you believe you don't don't
send them to a kennel I have a guy on
the east side do you live oh but you're
in New York exclusively now yeah there's
people that you can take me to its
normal
yeah well we'll talk fart mistress
concept for you Oh number because you're
going to do so here's the thing we're
talking about is that I should be I
should have been doing fart videos when
we were poor in 2008 I easily could have
done it and I was thinking of four
videos yeah
fart mistress calm no look for like just
like part it's not sorry porn you just
fart like feel like that lady easy
meeting head yeah click $300 right there
nice what do you put on on a website hey
webcam stuff yeah money for nothing
checks for free yeah I'd do that any um
wow I mean I Wow yeah it's a great way
to Mexico I'm saying and that guys want
to see girls do do it anyway in any way
home I have the perfect scenario for
make to make you for your public queen a
stripper debut you never find the
longest escalator or moving sidewalk and
I try to go the whole way I think
they're saying both fart past people to
get their reaction yes I did this before
at Disney World and for man-ho Florida
to several groups of unsuspecting
mommies I would pay to watch this oh my
god that farts shame and disgust all the
making of real retirement you do the
math
bye mommy thanks gene Ethan fart the
fart mistress will consider the
submission yeah yeah I farted check it
over try re I'm sorry here we go oh yeah
you like to read uh uh-huh
stomp
she's looking at it again she just kept
raising right I agree
it would've been funnier though the next
sentence in the fuckin story yeah yeah
like a monster see this is easy peasy it
is easy money it's not that I wouldn't
you do it you should do it well it's
very natural though right
it's supposed to be fetish yeah I think
you guys are onto something which was
spark Metris idea a couple ideas I had a
fart mistress Ford he gets pulled over
and has to fart her way out of it we
should write some fart fart like like
long-form is fart misters pregnant or
just gassy
a trip to the doctor and fart mistress
meets Bigfoot you'll never guess what
happens next
thanks for the taking the time to read
this I wish you luck in your fart
misters endeavors best regards the butt
plug connoisseur man Cady hey have you
ever gotten a colonoscopy no opposed to
yeah and so I got one too look at those
fucking hemorrhoids yeah they blow air
into your rectum so it's like wide open
yeah and then I look at whatever they
got a look at and then afterwards you
just pull of hair and so you feel like
if this ship you don't and then you fart
for about two straight days really yeah
just farting out air but crazy fart
graze you should charge for your next
one and have like a live feed of that
fart and people can pay to watch not
about it really alive what strange ona
actually right from there and I was like
I had to lie on the ground just fart the
whole time oh you capitalized yeah oh
thank god okay uh mention some of you
guys
yeah sure that I have drank a full glass
of water and this full bottle of Fiji
and you guys have not even come close
well yeah but when you hydrate
constantly I mean I had that and there's
coffee nothing
I peed already so like another one you
know anyway huh I'm done whatever done
been done for a minute
okay was the trick current champion yeah
I am oh really
please I'm also the observation champ
but that's another thing we'll go into
later we're going to do we're going to
wrap this up just let people know again
the special coming out double negative
children and adulthood on Netflix July
July 1 8 sly 1 8 less hi and then are
you working on are you already working
on building your next night
yeah ok my next special is gonna be all
about Judaism I decided oh really yeah
I'm going to really try to like flush
that out and exercise it are you going
to do it like in a Collin way where it's
like a almost like one-man show yeah I'm
going to look at it I mean I got to a
couple years in Edinboro so I really
sort of like been influenced by those
one man was like see and type show yeah
but I'm work out of clubs and like make
it like funny like American stand-up
yeah really all you want but like yeah
Colin be a good one the way Neal Brennan
did three mics is just interesting yeah
I'll watch a lot of stuff like that and
see how I'll figure out a mixture
between like stories laws and like
tradition great exciting awesome and
foreign to that yeah I got about like 20
now it's pretty shitty early on but I
mean but it's but it started and you
know it'll get this yeah so wait what's
the name of the new special say it again
double- double negative and it's a
double feature yeah yeah it's a double
feature like a double album yeah will it
play as one it'll plays to one stops to
the next we'll just like automatically
start playing almost like a new episode
yeah it's forward if you just watch one
and then leave the 45 and 45 so they're
like manageable time smart to do not 60
60 yeah smart I think so yeah also it's
too hard to get a crowd to like really
be in for an hour yeah you talked about
this right for now for two hours I mean
two hours a lot yeah for comedy yeah
yeah and then if you don't play it on
Netflix when you come back like to want
to resume playing you know just like any
stop watching house of cards to presume
that you want to resume are you sure
those double negatives I would show
house of cards I'm gonna heard of it
kids
right how's it far sorry and uh are you
into the new season I stopped the first
year oh you did some good of him talking
to me
just seemed like I really enjoy it yeah
no it was good when I watched it I
actually liked I just were yeah we can
try like seven episodes is gasps in
total no no I was the new season yeah
all right we got to go that you guys can
listen to the show thanks for having me
you guys got a lot going on here wrong
kind of houses ago or something a long
life yeah I think I was on this podcast
in three different places
oh yeah Redbury apartment that's right
all right your your beach house yeah
yeah Redondo and uh yeah now and Silver
Lake may be surreal no you are on I
think was in the silver lake house and
we had a Theo pian food wafting through
because our neighbor was we shared walls
right now at a place right yeah yeah
yeah I was I was gonna go on the back
it's fine that was a good time all right
all times are good times are you gonna
be on the road at all or no you just
show nah I'll be in Montreal no I'll be
my show the NASA show I'm hosting that
show okay Jay Robert Kelly Godfrey Jimmy
Carr it's a good show yeah it's a really
good show yamaneika sweet all right I'll
see you guys thanks for listening lots
of love yeah I love you mommy so thanks
[Music]
talking real car that it's
we're talking to your car but it's all
start talking real part that it's not
talking real car
[Music]
and we're talking real part at a five
five five
[Music]